SENATE COMMITTEE ONE HUNDRED
ENERGY WILL COME TO ORDER. GOOD
AFTERNOON LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
IN RESPONSE TO THE CORPORATE
NINETEEN ENERGY EMERGENCY
RATHER AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC IN THE LEGISLATORS
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND
ADHERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERINGS GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO CONTROL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THOSE IT TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE ALSO
HAVE REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
AND THE HYDROGEN INDUSTRY WHO
ARE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. FOR
OUR REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE
MUTE YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS
THIS WILL GREATLY AID IN THE
LIMITED ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK.
I ASK THAT EVERYONE TIME THAT
YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED THAT
YOU USE THE RAISE YOUR HAND IF
FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM. EACH
TIME YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO ON MUTE. PLEASE SELECT ON
MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING
R. I. T. PERSONNEL. WILL PUT
YOU BACK ON THE MUTE WHEN YOU
ARE DONE. ONE THREE ONE THREE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE THAT YOU CAN BE SEEN ON
THE SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME.
THEN YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT THE SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING THE TELECONFERENCE- IS
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
877-692-8953 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SEVEN ZERO FIVE SIX
NINE ZERO NINE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TEAM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. FOR
TODAY'S HEARING WILL BE HERE IN
ALL OF THE PANELS OF WITNESSES
ON THE AGENDA PRIOR TO TAKING
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT. ONCE WE
HAVE HEARD ALL THE WITNESSES WE
WILL HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT
PERIOD FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
COMMENT ON THE TOPICS OF
TODAY'S AGENDA. PLEASE NOTE
THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR
YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST
MUTE THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
TELEPHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WE HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
PARTICIPATION. I WILL MAINTAIN
THE DECORUM DURING THE HEARING
AS CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS AND
IT'S CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER
IT IS CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE
SOME LIKE TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO WERE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE. OF ONLINE TOOLS
OR TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
TODAY WILL BEGIN THE HEARING.
FROM REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
STATE AGENCIES AND THE HYDROGEN
INDUSTRY ABOUT THE CURRENT
STATE OF HYDROGEN AND THE
PROGRESS OF THE HYDROGEN
INDUSTRY. BEFORE WE BEGIN WITH
OUR SPEAKERS I WOULD LIKE TO
INVITE THE PUBLIC WANTED TO
PARTICIPATE TO CALL IN NOW.
PLEASE DIAL THIS TOLL FREE
NUMBER. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX
NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE THREE
WHEN PROMPTED PLEASE USE THE
ACCESS CODE. SEVEN ZERO FIVE
SIX NINE ZERO NINE. BEFORE WE
BEGIN WITH OUR FIRST PRESENTER
I WOULD LIKE TO REMIND THE
PUBLIC WATCHING AND THE CAN AND
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS THAT WE
WILL HEAR FROM ALL OF THE
PARTICIPANTS FIRST THEN WE WILL
MOVE TO QUESTIONS AND ANSWERS
SO PLEASE KEEP YOUR QUESTIONS
IN MIND TO WRITE THEM DOWN. AND
WE WILL ADDRESS THEM AT THE END.
I WOULD LIKE TO START BY
THANKING OUR PRESENTERS FOR
BEING HERE TODAY. AND AGREED
TO- STAY WITH US TO THE END OF
THE QUESTIONS AND ANSWER PERIOD
IT IS IMPORTANT FOR ALL OF US
TO HEAR FROM YOU. NOW LET'S
HEAR FROM OUR FIRST PRESENTER
DR JACK BAUER. AND A DOCTOR YOU
HAVE THIRTY MINUTES. AND THE
TIME IS YOURS SO PLEASE BEGAN.
ONLY. THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR
ARCHULETA- AND OTHER
DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS OF THIS
SENATE SELECT COMMITTEE. ANYONE
WHO CARES ABOUT ENERGY AND THE
ENVIRONMENT IS VERY THANKFUL
AND GRATEFUL FOR YOUR-
CONVENING OF THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO TALK ABOUT AND THEN TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT ACHIEVING ZERO
EMISSIONS. AND HYDROGEN I KNOW
IS GOING TO BE VERY IMPORTANT
FOR ACHIEVING ZERO EMISSIONS SO
I THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TO YOU. AND SINCE I'M
A UNIVERSITY PROFESSOR WHO
TEACHES ENGINEERING I ALWAYS
LIKE TO TALK ABOUT MY
THERMODYNAMICS CLASS AND THE
FIRST LAW OF THERMODYNAMICS
WHICH- EXPLAINS THAT ENERGY IS
CONSERVED. AND SO ON EARTH IF
WE DRAW CONTROL VOLUME AROUND
THIS WE ONLY HAVE A FEW THINGS
THAT CROSSED THIS CONTROL
VOLUME. THE PRIMARY ONE GOING
IN AND THROUGH THIS CONTROL
VOLUME A SOLAR RADIATION. SOME
OF THAT IS REFLECTED BACK OUT
IN THE SAME WAVELENGTH SPECTRUM
AS THE SUNS- WAVELENGTHS
THEMSELVES. AND THEN OTHER
RADIATION IS READING IT BACK
THROUGH THE CONTROL VOLUME OUT
TO SPACE IN A DIFFERENT
WAVELENGTH REGIME. BECAUSE THE
EARTH IS AT MUCH LOWER
TEMPERATURE THAN THE SUN. AND
OVER THE HISTORY OF THE EARTH.
THERE HAS BEEN THIS BALANCE
ALWAYS AND FOREVER THAT ANY
CHANGE AND ENERGY ON THE EARTH.
HAS THIS SOLAR RADIATION COMING
AND MINUS THAT WHICH IS
REFLECTED MONISTAT WHICH IS RE
RADIATED BACK OUT TO SPACE. AND
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT ALL THE
PRIMARY ENERGY RESOURCES THAT
WE TEND TO CONVERT HERE ON
EARTH HAVE COME FROM THIS
AMAZING BALANCE. WE'VE SEEN
OVER HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
YEARS TO MILLIONS OF YEARS DEAD
PLANT AND ANIMAL LIFE WITH THE
HEAT AND PRESSURE AGAIN BY THE
POWER OF THE SUN CONVERTED TO
FOSSIL FUELS LIKE COAL OIL AND
NATURAL GAS. AND THESE HAVE.
TAKES SO LONG TO MAKE ON EARTH
THAT I HAVE TO DRAW HASH MARKS
THROUGH THIS TIME FRAME.
BECAUSE ALL OF THE OTHER FORMS
OF PRIMARY ENERGY ARE-REPLENISHED NATURALLY ON EARTH
IN A MUCH SHORTER TIME FRAME SO
THINGS LIKE CORN TREES GRASS
USUALLY TAKE MONTHS OR YEARS TO
MAKE BIO ENERGY. IN THE FORM OF
ETHANOL OR BIO GAS OR BIO.
HYDROPOWER SUN POWER EVAPORATES
THE WATERS MAKES THE CLOUDS IN
THE CLOUDS RAIN ON TO THE HILLS
AND WE HAVE HYDROPOWER BUT THIS
TAKES ORDER OF MAGNITUDE WEEKS
TO MONTHS TO OCCUR AND WIND
POWER AGAIN BY THE POWER OF THE
SUN WE CREATE THESE PRESSURE
TEMPERATURE GRADIENTS THAT
BRITISH PRESSURE GRADIENTS AND
THE WIND BLOWS. BUT SOMETIMES
IT DOESN'T BLOW FOR DAYS. OR
EVEN WEEKS. WHEN SOLAR POWER IS
THE MOST PREDICTABLE AND
RELIABLY RETURN FORM OF ENERGY
THE INSTEAD WE USE A UNIT OF
SUN ENERGY UP. IT IS RETURNED
TO US. AT LEAST DURING THE DAY.
SO FROM AN ENGINEERING
PERSPECTIVE. IT'S QUITE OBVIOUS
THAT ENERGY SUSTAINABILITY
REQUIRES THAT WE CONVERT THESE
RESOURCES AT THE SAME RATE AT
WHICH- IS NATURALLY REPLENISHES
THEM. THIS IS A SIMPLE ENERGY
BALANCE. I ALSO ADDED THAT IT
SHOULD BE DONE WITHOUT
EXTERNALITIES. SO THIS IS HOW
WE ARE DOING WHEN IT COMES TO
FOSSIL FUEL USE ON EARTH. IN
THE TIME FRAME OF HUMAN HISTORY
IT'S QUITE OBVIOUS THAT WE ARE
NOT PRACTICING SUSTAINABLE
PRACTICES FOSSIL ENERGY YEARS
APPEARS AS A DELTA FUNCTION IN
THE COURSE OF HUMAN HISTORY.
IT'S QUITE OBVIOUSLY NOT
SUSTAINABLE. AND HERE WHAT
ABOUT THOSE EXTERNALITIES.
ENERGY CONVERSION FOR THE MOST
PART HAS IMPROVED QUALITY OF
LIFE AND FREEDOM FREEDOM OF
MOBILITY. BUT IT ALSO IS
UNFORTUNATELY THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL AND I SUGGEST
GEOPOLITICAL PROBLEMS. THESE
ARE THE THINGS THAT WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE ENERGY BALANCE YOU
DON'T SEE. SO FOR EXAMPLE THE
MOST IMPORTANT ONE FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE IS THE FACT THAT
THE SAME ENERGY CONVERSION
TECHNOLOGIES LEAD TO CRITERIA
POLLUTANT EMISSIONS AND WHILE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS LED
THE WORLD IN ADDRESSING
CRITERIA POLLUTANTS AND
IMPROVING AIR QUALITY WE STILL
HAVE SO MANY PLACES EVEN IN
THIS VERY WEALTHY AND- SUPER
STRICT REGIME PORT FOR
CONTROLLING. CRITERIA POLLUTANT
EMISSIONS WE STILL HAVE PEOPLE
WITH SERIOUS HEALTH
CONSEQUENCES WE STILL HAVE
PEOPLE THAT ARE DYING
PREMATURELY. FROM THESE
CONSEQUENCES OF WHAT WE ARE
DOING WITH ENERGY CONVERSION.
AND THEN WE HAVE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS WHICH AFFECT OUR
CLIMATE AND THESE INCLUDE MANY
FROM THE ENERGY CONVERSION LIKE
CARBON DIOXIDE METHANE AND
NITROUS OXIDE. AND THEN
RESOURCE RECOVERY DAMAGE LIKE
WE HAVE IN MIND OR REGIONAL
RESOURCE DEPLETION THAT LEADS
TO GEOPOLITICAL DEPENDENCIES
BUT THE ENERGY FUTURE MUST BE
MORE DIVERSE AND MORE EQUAL. TO
PROVIDE ACCESS TO THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT DON'T
CURRENTLY HAVE ACCESS. THIS IS
WHAT LEADS TO THOSE
GEOPOLITICAL DEPENDENCIES. AND
OF COURSE AS I SHOWED EARLIER.
HI MERRY ENERGY RESOURCE
DEPLETION IS SIMPLY NOT
SUSTAINABLE. BUT THERE'S REALLY
GOOD NEWS AND THE GOOD NEWS IS
FAIRLY RECENT BECAUSE SOLAR AND
WIND POWER AND BATTERY COSTS
FALL DRAMATICALLY FALLEN IN THE
LAST DECADE THEY HAVE FALLEN SO
MUCH AS A MATTER OF FACT THAT
AS A PRIMARY FORM OF ENERGY
THEY'RE THE CHEAPEST. SOLAR AND
WIND POWER THE CHEAPEST FORMS
OF PRIMARY ENERGY OUT THERE ON
THE MARKET TODAY. AND THIS
LEADS TO POPULAR THINKING THAT
WE SHOULD. MAKE ALL OF OUR
POWER FROM RENEWABLE SOURCES
INCLUDING SOLAR AND WIND
GEOTHERMAL AND OTHERS. AND AS A
RESULT USE THAT ALECTRA POWER
GENERATION IN ALL END USES. AND
USE BATTERIES TO HANDLE THIS
INTERMITTENCY ON THE GRID AND
FOR AND HOUSTON'S. AND SOME
THINK THIS IS ALL WE NEED. SOME
ALSO MAKE ARGUMENTS AGAINST THE
FACT THAT WE NEED HYDROGEN AND
FUEL CELLS THEY SAY SOMETHING
LIKE THIS MOST HYDROGEN TODAY
IS MADE FROM FSSIL FUELS
NATURAL GAS FOR MAKING HYDROGEN
FROM WATER AND ELECTRICITY IS
LESS EFFICIENT THAN CHARGING A
BATTERY OR MAKING ELECTRICITY
FROM HYDROGEN AND FUEL CELL IS
LESS EFFICIENT THAN A BATTERY
SO THAT. THE ROUND TRIP
EFFICIENCY OF THE HYDROGEN
ENERGY STORAGE TECHNOLOGY IS
LOWER THAN A BATTERY. AND THEY
ALSO SAY THAT HYDROGEN IS
DIFFICULT TO STORE AND MOVE
AROUND IN SOCIETY. AND VERY
INFLUENTIAL PEOPLE. PEOPLE THAT
I ADMIRE- MAKING ALL OF THESE
ARGUMENTS. INTERESTINGLY I
AGREE WITH MOST OF THE S.
HOWEVER. THIS IS SADLY
UNTRUTHFUL AND DOESN'T TELL THE
WHOLE STORY. WEMUST MAKE
CERTAIN SLIGHT MODIFICATIONS TO
THE STATEMENTS FOR THAT FOR IT
TO TELL THE WHOLE STORY BECAUSE
NOT ALL AND USES CAN BE
ELECTRIFIED. AND BATTERIES ARE
VERY IMPORTANT TO OUR
SUSTAINABLE ENERGY FUTURE BUT
THEY CAN'T HANDLE ALL OF THE
INTERMITTENCY UNDERGRAD. AND
THEY CAN'T BE USED FOR ALL AND
USES ONLY SOME. AND WHILE THE
ROUND TRIP EFFICIENCY IS LESS
IN GOING FROM ELECTRICITY TO
HYDROGEN BACK TO ELECTRICITY
THAN IT IS FOR A BATTERY. IT'S
ACTUALLY MORE EFFICIENT IF YOU
WANT LONG DURATION STORAGE. AND
WHILE HYDROGEN IS MORE
DIFFICULT TO MOVE AROUND IN
STORE INTO SOCIETY THIS IS ONLY
TRUE IF YOU COMPARE IT TO
FOSSIL FUELS. IT'S ACTUALLY
LIGHTER WEIGHT IN SOME CASES
MUCH EASIER TO MOVE ROUND IN
SOCIETY THAN BATTERIES FOR EGGS
FOR INSTANCE. SO WITH THESE
WHITE MODIFICATIONS YOU CAN SEE
THAT WE NEED NOT ONLY RENEWABLE
POWER GENERATION AND BATTERIES
BUT WE NEED RENEWABLE POWER
GESTURE GENERATION BATTERIES
AND- HYDROGEN AND FUEL CELL
TECHNOLOGY. AND WE'VE DONE LOTS
OF RESEARCH OVER THE YEARS TO
SHOW WHY WE NEED THIS AND ONE
OF THEM IS SIMPLY THE MAGNITUDE
THE AMOUNT OF STORAGE THAT WILL
BE REQUIRED FOR A 1100%
RENEWABLE GRADING CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS A SIMULATION THAT WE
DID QUITE A WHILE AGO WHERE WE
LOOKED AT THE FIFTEEN MINUTE BY
FIFTEEN MINUTE. AVAILABILITY OF
SUN AND WIND RESOURCES AND THE
DEMAND ON THE ELECTRIC GRID.
AND THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT WE
HAVE PLENTY OF PLACES WHERE WE
CAN PUT WINTER AND SUMMER
INFLUX SOLAR FARMS SO THAT WE
CAN MAKE ENOUGH RENEWABLE
ENERGY TO MAKE IT THROUGH THE
WHOLE YEAR WE HAVE ENOUGH
PRIMARY ENERGY RESOURCES. BUT
THE DYNAMICS OF THIS MATTER. IN
OTHER WORDS THERE ARE SOME
FIFTEEN MINUTE PERIODS SHOWN IN
THE READ THE DATA HERE. WHERE
THERE IS A DATA SET OF SUN AND
WIND POWER COMPARED TO THE
DEMAND. THEN THERE ARE OTHER
FIFTEEN MINUTE PERIODS WHERE
SHOWN IN THE BLUE DATA WE HAVE
A SURPLUS OF SUN AND WIND POWER.
SO NOW ALL WE NEED TO DO IS
JUST STORAGE AND TO MOVE IT
AROUND IN SOCIETY SO HOW DO WE
DO THAT TODAY WE HAVE A VERY
LARGE PUMPED HYDRO SYSTEM IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THIS IS SUPER IMPORTANT TO OUR
SUSTAINABLE ENERGY FUTURE. IF
WE WERE ABLE TO TURN ALL OF THE
PUMPS ON AT ONCE OKAY IN OUR
COMPUTER SYSTEM WE CAN CONSUME
ABOUT NINE GIGAWATTS OF
ELECTRICITY THAT'S THE HEIGHT.
OF THIS BOX HERE. AND IF WE HAD
ALL OF THE UPPER LAKE'S FULL
AND WE CAN PUT ALL OF THAT-
HYDRODYNAMIC ENERGY THROUGH
TURBINES TO MAKE ELECTRICITY WE
CAN ACTUALLY RETURN TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THAT SAME
NINE GIGAWATTS FOR ALMOST A
MONTH. THAT'S WHAT MAKES THIS
BOX OF THIS SIZE SO THIS IS A
VERY LARGE POWER AND ENERGY
CAPABLE. PUMPED HYDRO SYSTEM.
BUT YOU CAN SEE THAT IT'S NOT
ENOUGH TO ABSORB ALL OF THE
SERVICES. AND TO MOVE THEM ALL
TO THE DEFICITS SOME PEOPLE SAY
WELL LET'S JUST USE OUR BATTERY
ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND USE THOSE
TO MOVE THIS ENERGY AROUND AND
THIS IS A GOOD IDEA WE CAN MOVE
SOME OF IT AROUND- HOW BIG DO
YOU THINK THAT'LL BE THE L. IF
WE CONVERTED UP ALL TWENTY ONE
MILLION OF OUR LIGHT AND MEDIUM
DUTY VEHICLES. TO BATTERY
ELECTRIC VEHICLES WITH A SIXTY
TWO KILOWATT HOUR BATTERY
THAT'S THE NISSAN LEAF
EQUIVALENT BATTERY. THIS IS A
LARGE EIGHT POWER. DEMAND TO
GET COULD ABSORB. WHICH IS VERY
LARGE ORDER THIRTY GIGAWATTS.
ONLY STORES ENOUGH ENERGY FR
ABOUT FOUR HOURS. SO THIS ALSO
MAY HELP WITH THE SHORT
DURATION DYNAMICS BUT REALLY
CAN'T MOVE ALL OF THIS ENERGY
THAT'S ACCESS IN THE SUMMER TO
THE FALL AND WINTER AS IT'S
NEEDED. ON THE OTHER HAND IF WE
SIMPLY CONVERTED EXISTING GAS
STORAGE FACILITIES TO HYDROGEN.
THIS IS A LARGE THAT RESOURCE
WOULD BE. IT'S THE ONLY
RESOURCE THAT IS OF THE
MAGNITUDE. THAT THE 1100%
RENEWABLE GRID REQUIRES IT'S
THE ONLY RESOURCE THAT COULD
POSSIBLY TAKE ALL OF THE ACCESS
IN ONE SEASON AND DELIVER IT TO
THE OTHER SEASONS SO THAT WE
CAN MAKE OUR CALIFORNIA GRANT.
101% RENEWABLE. BATTERIES ARE
VERY IMPORTANT AND SHOULD BE
SUPPORTED BUT THEY WILL NEVER
BE BIG ENOUGH TO GO ALL THE WAY
TO A 100% HYDROGEN ON THE OTHER
HAND IS. WE DID THIS ANALYSIS
ALSO FOR THE ENTIRE WORLD
LOOKING AT THE DYNAMICS OF SUN
AND WIND IN VARIOUS CONTINENTS
OKAY AND VARIOUS AMOUNTS OF SUN
AND WIND IN THESE CONTINENTS
AND STUDYING THE HOUR BY HOUR
AVAILABILITY OF THOSE RESOURCES
AND COUPLE THAT TO THE DEMAND
DYNAMICS AND WE- ASSESS THE BAN
FOR ONE FOR A WORLD TO BECOME
1100% RENEWABLE WE NEEDED MORE
THAN TWENTY THOUSAND TERAWATT
HOURS OF ENERGY STORAGE. THE
VERY BEST BATTERIES IN THE
WORLD TODAY ARE MADE WITH
LITHIUM AND COBALT THESE ARE
WITH THE- ION BATTERIES THIS
WOULD REQUIRE MORE THAN THREE
THOUSAND MEGATONS OF LITHIUM
AND MORE THAN TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED MEGATONS
OF COBALT. TO MAKE THE VERY
FIRST OKAY BATTERY USING THE
BEST BATTERY TECHNOLOGY IN THE
WORLD THE BILL THAT ONE BATTERY
US TWENTY THOUSAND TERAWATT
HOURS. UNFORTUNATELY ON EARTH
IF YOU LOOK AT THE RESOURCES
THAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE THERE'S
ONLY FIFTY THREE MEGATONS OF
LITHIUM AND ONLY TWENTY FIVE
MEGATONS ON EARTH- ON
TERRESTRIAL. LOCATIONS ON EARTH
AND MORE THAN A HUNDRED TWENTY
MEGATONS ON THE OCEAN FLOOR IF
WE DECIDED TO MIND THAT BUT
WHAT YOU CAN SEE HERE IS THAT
THE WORLD'S VERY BEST BATTERIES.
ARE MADE WITH THESE RESOURCES
THAT ARE TOTALLY INSUFFICIENT.
TO BE USED FOR GRAND SCALE
STORAGE. IN ADDITION MORE THAN
60% OF THE COBALT COMES FROM
THE DEMOCRATIC REPUBLIC OF
CONGO THAT DOESN'T HAVE
SUSTAINABLE NON BUSINESS
PRACTICES OR CHILD LABOR LAWS.
I SUGGEST THAT WE SHOULD USE
BATTERIES WHERE THEY MAKE THE
MOST SENSE IN LIGHT DUTY
VEHICLES AND IN CELLULAR PHONES
AND PERSONAL ELECTRONICS THERE
IS WHERE WE NEED THEM FOR A
SUSTAINABLE ENERGY FUTURE.
THERE IS NOT ENOUGH LITHIUM OR
COBALT IN THE WORLD TO USE IT
FOR THESE MASSIVE STORAGE
REQUIREMENTS OF A TOTALLY
RENEWABLE GRID. SH ADDITION
BATTERIES ARE SUPER EFFICIENT
IF YOU SH STORE ENERGY FOR A
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME THIS IS
DATA FROM THE CALIFORNIA'S SELF
GENERATION INCENTIVE PROGRAM
ADVANCED ENERGY STORAGE
PROJECTS- AND WHAT YOU CAN SEE.
IS THE ROUND TRIP EFFICIENCY
THAT'S WHAT'S PLOTTED HERE
VERSUS THE CAPACITY FACTOR AND
CAPACITY FACTORS ESSENTIALLY
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT TIME.
BETWEEN THE CHARGING AND
DISCHARGING OKAY SO IF YOU HAVE
A HIGH CAPACITY FACTOR THAT
MEANS YOU'RE CHARGED. LET'S SAY
ONE DAY AND THE VERY NEXT
EVENING YOU JUST CHARGE.
SOMETHING LIKE THAT BUT IF YOU
HAVE A LOW CAPACITY FACTOR THAT
MEANS YOU CHARGE ONE DAY YOU
STARTED FOR A WEEK AND THEN YOU
JUST TARGET FOR EVEN LONGER
THAN THAT. WHAT YOU CAN SEE
HERE S THAT THE AVERAGE OF
THESE GRANTS SIZED UTILITY
APPLICATIONS OF BATTERY SYSTEMS
IS THE AVERAGE ROUNDTRIP
EFFICIENCY IS AROUND 60% AND
THIS IS PRIMARILY DUE TO SELF
DISCHARGE SOMETHING WE ARE
FAMILIAR WITH FROM THE
BATTERIES WE USE IN OUR CELL
PHONES OR IN OUR CARS WE KNOW
THAT IF WE DON'T USE IT FOR
QUITE AWHILE IT DISCHARGES. AND
THIS IS BECAUSE THE STORAGE
MEDIUM IS AN INTIMATE CONTACT
WITH THE ELECTRODES AND THERE'S
NO WAY OF. EVENTING COMPLETELY
PSALM DISCHARGE. AND THIS IS
WHY WHEN IT COMES TO LONG
DURATION STORAGE BATTERIES ARE
NOT WELL SUITED TO THIS
HYDROGEN IS BETTER SUITED TO
THE MASSIVE AND LONG DURATION
STORAGE THAT WE NEED AT THAT
UTILITY SCALE. AND THE DYNAMICS
WORK VERY WELL FOR HYDROGEN
THIS IS RESEARCH THAT WE DID
QUITE A WHILE AGO LOOKING AT
TEXAS WIND YOU CAN SEE THE WIND
DYNAMICS THAT ARE SHOWN HERE
WHEN I TRY TO GET A POINTER.
GOING YOU CAN SEE THE WIND
DYNAMICS AND GREEN HERE AND YOU
CAN SEE THE DEMAND DYNAMICS OF
AN ADJACENT TOWN IN MAGENTA AND
THEN YOU CAN SEE WHENEVER THERE
IS ACCESS WIND WE CAN PUT IT
THROUGH AN ELECTROLYZER AND
MAKE RENEWABLE HYDROGEN FROM
THAT ACCESS GRANTED WHENEVER
THERE'S A DEFICIT OF WHEN WE
ACTUALLY TAKE THE HYDROGEN OUT
OF THE SALT CAVERN THAT WE
STARTED IN AND PUT IT THROUGH A
FUEL CELL SO THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY MEET THE DEMAND OF
THIS ADJACENT CITY- AT EVERY
HOUR OF THE YEAR THIS IS JUST
SHOWING ONE WEEK IN OCTOBER. WE
FOUND THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY
MANAGE THE PRESSURE AND
TEMPERATURE DYNAMICS IN THE
SALT CAVERN WHERE RESTORING ALL
THE HYDROGEN TO. BELOW MAXIMUM
AN ABOVE MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS.
IF YOU LOOK AT IT FOR THE WHOLE
YEAR SHOWN HERE ON THE RIGHT
HAND SIDE YOU CAN SEE THAT OUR
BY OUR MINUTE BY MINUTE. AND
EVEN MONTH BY MONTH WE ARE ABLE
TO STORE WINDPOWER AND COUPLE
IT COMPLETELY TO THE ENERGY
DEMAND IN THIS CITY IN TEXAS
YOU CAN SEE HERE THAT ACCESS
OVERALL. WIN POWER IN OCTOBER
NOVEMBER DECEMBER JANUARY
FEBRUARY MARCH. IS ACTUALLY
RETURNED PRIMARILY IN JULY
AUGUST AND SEPTEMBER TO THAT
COMMUNITY. SO YOU CAN SEE WE
CAN DO THE HOUR BY HOUR AND
SEASONAL. COMPLEMENTING OF WIND
POWER TO THE DEMAND SO WHAT WE
DON'T HAVE A SALT CAVERN. WELL
I SUGGEST THAT WE HAVE
UNDERGROUND STORAGE
TRANSMISSION AND DISTRIBUTION
SYSTEM TODAY THAT CAN BE
CONVERTED WITH SOME INVESTMENT
TO- STORE AND DISTRIBUTE THIS
VALUABLE RESOURCE AS A MATTER
OF FACT RECENT STUDIES BY THE
GAS TECHNOLOGY INSTITUTE
SUGGESTS THAT THE RELIABILITY
OF THIS UNDERGROUND
INFRASTRUCTURE IS MORE THAN
FIVE NINES THROUGHOUT THE
NATION. SO HYDROGEN IS GOING TO
BE IMPORTANT FOR RESILIENCY.
FOR MASSIVE STORAGE AND FOR
TRANSMISSION DISTRIBUTION
ESPECIALLY IN PLACES LIKE
CALIFORNIA WHERE WE ALREADY
HAVE CHALLENGES WITH MOVING ALL
OF OUR ENERGY THROUGH- FROM THE
DESERT AND- BORDER AREAS INTO
URBAN AREAS WE HAVE CHALLENGES
WITH WILDFIRES GET CHALLENGES
WITH S. P. S. P. S. EVENTS THAT
CAN BE HELPED BY AN INVESTMENT
IN THE TRANSFORMATION OF OUR
GAS SYSTEM. AND IT IS A MASSIVE
RESOURCE AS A MATTER OF FACT.
THIRTEEN TERAWATT HOURS OF
EQUIVALENT ELECTRICITY STORAGE
CAN BE ACCOMMODATED JUST IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA SERVICE
TERRITORY THIS IS WORTH TWO
POINT SIX TRILLION DOLLARS AT
FUTURE BATTERY COST. EVEN IF WE
JUST IJECTED 5% HIGHER CHEN
INTO THE NATURAL GAS THIS IS AN
EQUIVALENT STORAGE SYSTEM THAT
WOULD BE WORTH ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY BILLION DOLLARS IN
DEALING FUTURE BATTERY COSTS.
THIS IS SUCH A LARGE STORAGE
AND TRANSMISSION AND
DISTRIBUTION RESOURCE. THAT
EVEN JUST 5% OF IT. IS THIS
VALUABLE HOW THESE NUMBERS ARE
SO BIG IN MY MIND I HAVE A HARD
TIME BECAUSE- MATCHING WHAT HOW
BIG THEY ARE SO I COMPARED IT
TO SOMETHING I KNOW MORE ABOUT
LIKE. THE TUITION AND FEES AT
UC IRVINE AND WE COULD SEND THE
ENTIRE ORANGE COUNTY POPULATION
MORE THAN TWO POINT TWO MILLION
PEOPLE. TO FOUR YEARS OF THE
ENTIRE POPULATION IT WOULD ONLY
COST THIRTY NINE BILLION
DOLLARS OR WE CAN MAKE ALL
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS FREE TO EVERYONE AND
EVERY FOUR YEARS WE ONLY HAVE
TO COME UP WITH A FOUR POINT
SEVEN BILLION. SOME SOMETHING
ABOUT THIS. TRANSFORMING THE
GAS SYSTEM TO JUST ACCEPT 5%
HYDROGEN. OKAY WOULD BE WORSE A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY BILLION
DOLLARS. THE INTERESTING OF
WHICH WOULD EASILY PAY FOR ALL
OF THIS. IT'S EXTREMELY
VALUABLE TO OUR RESILIENT AND
ZERO EMISSIONS FUTURE. AND FUEL
CELL SYSTEMS OPERATING OFF OF
GAS DELIVERED AN UNDERGROUND
GAS UNDERGROUND GAS SYSTEM HAVE
PROVEN THIS RESILIENCE THROUGH
ALL SORTS OF NATURAL DISASTERS
LIKE THE SAN DIEGO BLACKOUT
THAT OCCURRED IN TWENTY ELEVEN
WINTER STORMS IN THE NORTHEAST
EARTHQUAKES LIKE THE NAPA
EARTHQUAKE IN CALIFORNIA
RECENTLY. OR THE RIDGECREST
EARTHQUAKE EVEN MORE RECENTLY
THE MANHATTAN BLACKED OUT
JAPANESE SUPER TYPHOONS
HUNDREDS OF EXAMPLES OF THIS
BEING PROVEN BY THE GAS SYSTEM
AND FUEL CELLS. WE ALSO NEED
HYDROGEN FOR OTHER THINGS AND I
WAS VERY FORTUNATE TO WORK WITH
SOME AWESOME SCIENTISTS AND
ENGINEERS LED BY MY COLLEAGUE
STEVE DAVIS HERE AND WE
FORTUNATELY WE WERE LOOKING AT
HOW DO WE MAKE THE ENTIRETY OF
OUR ENERGY SYSTEM ZERO
EMISSIONS. AND HYDROGEN PLAYS A
VERY IMPORTANT ROLE IN MANY OF
THESE THINGS OF COURSE WE NEED
PRIMARY SUN AND WIND ENERGY BUT
WE ALSO NEED THINGS THAT DEPEND
UPON HYDROGEN LIKE THE
PRODUCTION OF AMMONIA. OR THE
PRODUCTION OF AVIATION OR
TRANSPORTATION LIQUID FUELS
ABOUT CEMENT AND STEEL OR HOW
ABOUT MAKING HOSPITALS AS
RESILIENT AS POSSIBLE THESE
KINDS OF THINGS NEED THE
FEATURES. THAT HYDROGEN
PROVIDES OF COURSE IN ADDITION
TO INVESTMENTS IN SOLAR WIND
BATTERIES ETCETERA. AND IN
PARTICULAR WHEN IT COMES TO
FUELS THERE ARE VERY DIFFICULT
TO ELECTRIFY AND USES. SOME OF
OUR SHOWN HERE LIKE FUEL CELL
BUSES OR SHIPS OR AIRCRAFT OR
LONG HAUL TRUCKS OR TRAINS.
LITERALLY ANYTHING THAT WOULD
REQUIRE RAPID FUELING OR LONG
RANGE OR LARGE PAYLOAD IN THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR TENDS TO
PREFER ZERO EMISSIONS WITH
HYDROGEN. TWO ZERO EMISSIONS
WITH BATTERIES YEAH BOTH OF
THESE ARE IMPORTANT BUT IF YOU
NEED THESE FEATURES HYDROGEN
WILL BE PREFERRED FOR ZERO
EMISSIONS. THERE ARE MANY
INDUSTRIAL END USES LIKE STEEL
CEMENT PLASTICS PHARMACEUTICALS
CHIP. COMPUTER CHIP FABRICATION
OR A MILLION FERTILIZER
PRODUCTION AND MANY OTHERS THAT
CANNOT BE ELECTRIFIED BECAUSE
OF THE REQUIREMENTS FOR HEAT OR
FEEDSTOCK OR REDUCING GAS THIS
CAN BE DELIVERED ON THE OTHER
HAND BY HYDROGEN. AND THEN WE
COME TO THE COLORS OF HYDROGEN.
WELL FIRST OF ALL THERE'S NO
ACCEPTED OR AGREED TO STANDARD
ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD. I'VE PUT
TOGETHER AN EXAMPLE HERE OF.
MANY COLORS OF HYDROGEN THAT
PEOPLE ARE SUGGESTING AND WHILE
THIS MIGHT MAKE FOR A COLORFUL
RAINBOW. I SUGGEST THAT PICKING
WINNERS AND LOSERS INHIBITS
WHAT WE DESIRE. IMAGE THE
MARKET INVESTMENT AND OFTEN IT
LEADS TO UNEXPECTED NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES. OFTEN INCREASING
EMISSIONS RATHER THAN
DECREASING THEM AS WE DESIRE.
SO I STRONGLY SUGGEST THAT WE
DO NOT ESTABLISH THIS SORT OF A
COLOR PREFERENCE BUT RATHER USE
ALREADY ESTABLISHED MEANS OF
ASSESSING CARBON UNTESTED
INTENSITY OR ASSESSING THE
EMISSIONS IMPACTS THIS IS THE
METRIC THAT WE SHOULD USE FOR
ASSESSING WHETHER OR NOT WE'RE
DOING SOMETHING DESIRABLE BY
ADOPTING HYDROGEN. ONE AND WITH
TWO THINGS THAT WE THAT THAT WE
HAVE ANALYZED IN SOME DEGREE OF
DETAIL HERE ONE OF THEM IS CAN
WE MAKE THE PORT OF LA LONG
BEACH COMPLETELY ZERO
EMISSIONS. AND WE LOOKED AT
BATTERY SAYS ONE OF THE
SOLUTION AND HYDROGEN IS ONE OF
THE SOLUTIONS FOR THE SHIPS FOR
EXAMPLE WHAT YOU'RE SEEING HERE
IS THE PERCENT OF ORIGINAL
CARGO SPACE AND THAT TONNAGE
THAT A HYDROGEN OPTION AND A
BATTERY OPTION COULD ENGENDER
AND IT'S VERY APPLAUDED VERSES
THE SHIP'S SIZE IN THOUSANDS OF
TWENTY FOOT EQUIVALENT UNITS
OKAY SO YOU CAN SEE THIS IS ONE
THOUSAND TWO YEAR AND ASSIST
THIRTEEN THOUSAND TWO YEAR. AND
WHEN YOU CAN SEE ALMOST
IMMEDIATELY IS THAT THE BATTERY
CASES ARE SEVERELY DIMINISHED
AND FOR THE MOST PART HAVE
HARDLY ANY TONNAGE THAT'S LEFT
ONCE YOU OUTFIT THEM WITH
BATTERIES IT'S NOT POSSIBLE TO
MAKE SHIPS ZERO EMISSION WITH
BATTERIES ON THE OTHER HAND
BOTH HYDROGEN GASTRIN IN THE
GREEN DATA AND HYDROGEN LIQUID
SHOWN IN THE READ DATA. HAVE
SUFFICIENT VOLUME IN TONNAGE TO
MAKE IT FEASIBLE AS A MATTER OF
FACT IN PARTICULAR IN THE
LIQUID HYDROGEN CASES 1100% OF
THE ORIGINAL CUT TO CARGO SPACE
AND TONNAGE IS ALMOST EXACTLY
ATTAINABLE WITH A HYDROGEN.
SHIP OPTION. AND THEN YOU CAN
TAKE THOSE SHIPS OVER GREAT
DISTANCES THIS IS LIKE
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND NAUTICAL
MILES AND YOU CAN SEE HERE THE
CARGO THAT IS ABLE TO BE TAKEN
BY HYDROGEN CHIPS. CAN YOU GO
CAN CAN GO A LONG WAYS AND CAN
STILL BE ORDER OF MAGNITUDE THE
SAME AMOUNT OF CARGO THAT WERE
CUT CARRYING TODAY. AND IF WE
DID THIS AND WE TOOK ALL THE
SHIPS ALL THE TRAINS ALL THE
TRUCKS. EIGHT POINT NINE
MILLION TONS OF HYDROGEN TO BE
GENERATED EVERY YEAR SO CAN WE
MAKE THAT MUCH TIGHTER JOHN.
ISNER FACT WE'VE ANALYZED JUST
OFFSHORE WIND AND JUST THREE
OFFSHORE WIND FARMS IN THESE
LOCATIONS AND THE COST OF THIS
OFFSHORE WIND IS COMING DOWN
VERY SUBSTANTIALLY COULD MAKE.
ALL OF THAT HYDROGEN EVERY YEAR.
THIS IS A VISION FOR THE FUTURE
THAT CANNOT BE ENGENDERED.
WITHOUT HYDROGEN. WINDPOWER IN
THREE LARGE WIND FARMS CAN MAKE
THE ENTIRETY OF THE L. A. LONG
BEACH COURT ZERO EMISSIONS.
WE'VE ALSO BEEN LOOKING A LOT
OF DATA CENTERS RECENTLY AND-
HERE IS AN EXAMPLE OF DATA
CENTERS THAT WE ANALYZED TO
PRODUCE ALL OF THE PRIMARY
ENERGY FROM SUN AND WIND AND TO
USE BATTERIES OR POWER TO GAS-
IN VARIOUS CONFIGURATIONS TO
MEET THE DEMAND DYNAMICS IN
VARIOUS LOCATIONS TWO. AND
THESE ARE THE MODELING
ASSUMPTIONS THAT WE MADE AND
YOU CAN SEE HERE WE DO INDEED
HAVE LOWER ROUND TRIP
EFFICIENCY FOR THE HYDROGEN
CASES THAN WE DO FOR THE
BATTERY CASES. AND WE HAVE TO
ACCOUNT FOR LIQUEFACTION WHEN
WE MAKE HYDROGEN AT SUCH A
LARGE SCALE THE SCALE THAT DATA
CENTERS REQUIRE AND SO IT TAKES
A LOT OF ENERGY AND IT ALSO HAS
SOME BOIL OFF LOSSES WHICH WE
ACCOUNT FOR. BUT IF AND WE CAN
ALSO OPTIMIZE THESE SO FOR
EXAMPLE WE CAN OPTIMIZE IT FOR
IT FOR THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT OF
ENERGY FROM THE SUN AND WHEN IT
GOES TO THE DATA CENTER
DIRECTLY. REACHING 81% THAT
SOUNDS LIKE A LOT IT IS. BUT WE
STILL NEED QUITE A BIT OF
STORAGE IS NOT EFFECTIVE WE
INSTALL MORE SOLAR AND WIND
POWER THEN WE HAVE A SMALLER
ENERGY STORAGE SYSTEM WE CAN
OPTIMIZE FOR THAT TOO. BUT WE
WANT TO OPTIMIZE FOR THE LOWEST
CAPACITY INSTALLED WE HAVE TO
PICK MOSTLY MEN OUR- SO ALL OF
THESE WE'VE ANALYZED. AND IN
EVERY SINGLE CASE WHERE WE'RE
LOOKING AT THESE WERE LOOKING
AT THE LEVELIZED COST OF
ELECTRICITY DELIVERED TO THE
DATA CENTER. REMEMBER THIS IS
FOR A 100% RENEWABLE ACCOUNTING
FOR ALL OF THE STORAGE ALL OF
THE LOSSES. FOR GETTING THROUGH
THE ENTIRETY OF A YEAR- AND
DELIVERING THIS- ELECTRICITY TO
THE DATA CENTER AND WE CAN SEE
WE HAVE TO INSTALL A LOT MORE
WIND AND- SOLAR P. V. IN THE
HYDROGEN CASE BECAUSE OF THAT
LOWER ROUND TRIP EFFICIENCY.
BUT BECAUSE OF SEPARATE POWER
AND ENERGY SCALING FEATURES.
AND BECAUSE OF. THE HUGE
MAGNITUDE OF STORAGE THAT'S
REQUIRED FOR THE C. HYDROGEN
CASES ARE ALWAYS. VERY MUCH
MARK EFFECTIVE SHOWING HERE ON
AND TWENTY DOLLARS MEGAWATT
HOUR VERSUS ALMOST FULL
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER HOUR FOR
THE BATTER CASE EVERYTHING CASE
THAT WE LOOKED AT 4100%
RENEWABLE WITH ALL THE STORAGE.
INCLUDED IS CHEAPER WHEN WE GO
THE HYDROGEN ROUTE. THE DOCTOR
LIMB INTERRUPTING IT GIVE YOU A
ONE MINUTE FOR CLOSING AND WILL
CONTINUE WITH THE OTHER
PANELISTS YES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SO I WASN'T ABLE TO
DISCUSS ALL OF THE FEATURES
THAT HYDROGEN CAN PROVIDE BUT
WE WROTE A PAPER ON THIS AND I
HAVEN'T REFERENCED HERE-
HYDROGEN OFFERS SOME
INTERESTING AND UNIQUE FEATURES
AS A ZERO EMISSIONS FACTOR.
THAT ARE GOING TO BE REQUIRED
FOR A 100% RENEWABLE AND ZERO
EMISSIONS FACTOR- ZERO
EMISSIONS ECONOMY. I THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO
YOU TODAY AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE. THANK YOU
DOCTOR WILL HAVE A QUESTIONS
YEAR AFTER THE- YES SPEAKER SO
LET'S GO ON AND- ONCE AGAIN DR
BOWERS DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL
FUEL CELL RESEARCH CENTER AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
IRVINE. AND THANK YOU DOCTOR
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY NEXT WE'LL
HEAR FROM THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD- MISTER ANDREW
MARTINEZ AND YOU HAVE FIFTEEN
MINUTES SIR. PLEASE WELCOME
AND- THE FLOOR IS YOURS. ARE
YOU ALL ABLE TO SEE MY SCREEN.
WITH THE PRESENTATION. YES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARE GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU CHARGE
A LETTER PROVIDING HERE TODAY
TO PROVIDE THIS UPDATE ON
CALIFORNIA'S LIGHT DUTY
HYDROGEN STATION NETWORK
DEVELOPMENT AND CARDS ANALYSES
OF PROGRESS TO DATE AND OUTLOOK
FOR THE FUTURE. THERE ARE HUGE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR HYDROGEN AND
THE MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
SECTORS BUT THIS PRESENTATION
TODAY IS FOCUSED ON THE LIGHT
DUTY SECTOR. FOR MANY YEARS
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN A GLOBAL
LEADER IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
HYDROGEN FUELING STATION
NETWORK DEVELOPMENT. AND FUEL
CELL ELECTRIC VEHICLE
DEPLOYMENT. IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
THROUGH ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT THE
LEGISLATURE ESTABLISHED A
TARGET OF AT LEAST ONE HUNDRED
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE HYDROGEN
FILLING STATIONS. THAT BILL
ENABLES FUNDING FOR AT LEAST
ONE HUNDRED STATIONS IN
OPERATION CALIFORNIA. OR UNTIL
THE ENERGY COMMISSION IN
CONSULTATION WITH KERR. FINDS
THAT THE PRIVATE SECTOR IS
ESTABLISHING SUCH STATIONS
WITHOUT THE NEED FOR PUBLIC
SUPPORT. GOVERNOR BROWN THEN
ESTABLISHED A SECOND TARGET IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO EXECUTIVE
ORDER B. FORTY EIGHT EIGHTEEN.
THAT WATER SET A TARGET OF TWO
HUNDRED HYDROGEN FUELING
STATIONS BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
ALONG WITH OTHER TARGETS FOR
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
DEPLOYMENT AND CHARGING NETWORK
DEVELOPMENT. CALIFORNIA
STRATEGY INCORPORATES FINANCIAL
AND NON FINANCIAL SUPPORT
MECHANISMS TO ACHIEVE THESE
CHARGING STATION NETWORK
DEVELOPMENT GOALS SUPPORT THE
CONSTRUCTION OPERATION OF
HYDROGEN FUELING STATIONS. AND
PROVIDE ANALYSIS AND GUIDANCE
FOR PUBLIC AND PRIVATE EFFORTS.
THROUGH THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM EXTENDED
BY AB EIGHT THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION PROVIDES UP
TO TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS PER
YEAR NOT TO EXCEED 20% OF
PROGRAM FUNDING AND COMPETITIVE
GRANTS TO CO FUND THE
DEVELOPMENT OF LIGHT DUTY
HYDROGEN FILLING STATIONS UNTIL
JANUARY FIRST. TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR. ADDITIONALLY CARBS LOW
CARBON FUEL STANDARD PROGRAM
PROVIDES TWO MECHANISMS TO
SUPPORT THE OPERATIONS OF
HYDROGEN FILLING STATIONS. AS
IS THE CASE WITH OTHER
ALTERNATIVE FUELS HYDROGEN
STATION OPERATORS MAY GENERATE
CREDITS IN THE PROGRAM ON THE
BASIS OF SALES OF HYDROGEN FUEL.
IN TWENTY NINETEEN THE LTFS
REGULATION WAS AMENDED TO
INCLUDE A SECOND PATHWAY THAT
ALLOWS STATION OPERATORS TO
GENERATE ADDITIONAL CREDITS UP
TO THE CAPACITY OF EACH
STATION. FOR A LIMITED PERIOD
OF TIME AND WITHIN CERTAIN
LIMITATIONS. THIS PROVIDES AN
ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITY FOR
REVENUE THAT CAN SUPPORT
STATION OPERATIONS WHILE FUEL
CELL ELECTRIC VEHICLE
DEPLOYMENT GROWS OVER TIME. IN
ADDITION TO THE FINANCIAL
SUPPORT MECHANISMS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA PROVIDES SEVERAL NON
FINANCIAL SUPPORT PROGRAMS.
TESTING THAT EVALUATES HYDROGEN
STATION FEELING PROTOCOLS
ACCURATE METERING AND FEEL
PURITY ARE CARRIED OUT BY STAFF
AT CARD AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE'S DIVISION OF
MEASUREMENT STANDARDS. THESE
PROGRAMS PROVIDE VALUE BY
ENSURING THAT STATIONS OPERATE
AS EXPECTED ACCORDING TO
INDUSTRY ACCEPTED STANDARDS.
PROVIDE POSITIVE FEELING
EXPERIENCES FOR FUEL CELL
ELECTRIC VEHICLE DRIVERS. THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT OR GO
BIDS ALSO PROVIDE SUPPORT TO
STATION DEVELOPERS AND HAVE
DEVELOPED A PERMITTING
GUIDEBOOK. UNDER ABA CARBONI
ENERGY COMMISSION ALSO PROVIDE
ANALYSIS AND EVALUATION OF
PROGRESS IN NETWORK DEVELOPMENT
AND FUEL CELL VEHICLE
DEPLOYMENT. POTENTIAL FUTURE
DEVELOPMENTS AND ASSESSMENT OF
NEEDS. THE FIRST RETAIL
HYDROGEN STATION IN CALIFORNIA
BEGAN OPERATIONS IN WEST
SACRAMENTO IN TWENTY FIFTEEN.
SINCE THEN THE NETWORK HAS
EXPANDED WITH MAJOR CLUSTERS OF
HYDROGEN FILLING STATIONS IN
THE SACRAMENTO AREA AROUND THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA AND IN
ORANGE AND LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
ADDITIONAL STATIONS ARE LOCATED
IN SAN DIEGO RIVERSIDE SANTA
BARBARA AND TRUCKEE NEAR LAKE
TAHOE. STATION KALANGA SERVES A
VITAL ROLE IN ENABLING TRAVEL
BETWEEN NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN
HALVES OF THE STATE. TODAY
CALIFORNIA'S HYDROGEN FUELING
STATION NETWORK CONSISTS OF
FIFTY TWO TOTAL STATIONS THAT
ARE CAPABLE OF RETAIL HYDROGEN
FUEL CELLS WITH FORTY EIGHT OF
THESE CURRENTLY AVAILABLE TO
THE PUBLIC. THESE STATIONS ARE
SHOWN ON THE MAP ON THE RIGHT
WHICH ALSO HIGHLIGHTS THE
STATIONS THAT HAVE OPENED SINCE
CARD PUBLISHED IT'S TWENTY
TWENTY. ANNUAL EVALUATION OF
HYDROGEN STATION NETWORK
DEVELOPMENT AND FUEL CELL
ELECTRIC VEHICLE DEPLOYMENT.
NEARLY EVERYONE OF THESE
STATIONS HAS BEEN DEVELOPED TO
THE CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM. MOST ALSO PARTICIPATE
IN THE AVAILABLE CREDIT
GENERATION OPPORTUNITIES
THROUGH THE LOW CARBON FUEL
STANDARD. UP TO AN ADDITIONAL
ONE HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN
STATIONS ARE EITHER CURRENTLY
UNDER CONSTRUCTION OR PLANNED
FOR FUTURE DEVELOPMENT. UP TO
ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY STATIONS
HAVE BEEN POTENTIALLY AWARDED
GRANTS FOR CONSTRUCTION UNDER
THE CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM. NINETY FOUR OF WHICH
WERE RECENTLY AWARDED THE
ENERGY COMMISSION'S LATEST
MULTI YEAR GRANT SOLICITATION
GFO NINETEEN SIX OH TWO. SOME
ARE CURRENTLY UNDER DEVELOPMENT
WHILE OTHERS ARE PENDING FUTURE
ALLOCATIONS FOR CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM
INVESTMENT PLANS. GRANTS ARE
ALSO AWARDED TO UPGRADE STATION
CAPACITY UP FOR EXISTING
HYDROGEN FUELING STATIONS. THE
STATION FASSIE UPGRADES ARE
NECESSARY BECAUSE THERE HAVE
BEEN SOME LOCAL STATIONS WITH
HIGH DEMAND EVEN THOUGH THE
OVERALL NETWORK CAPACITY
EXCEEDS USE AT THIS POINT. AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY THREE
STATIONS ARE EITHER CURRENTLY
UNDER CONSTRUCTION OR PLANNED
FOR FUTURE DEVELOPMENT THROUGH
COMPLETELY PRIVATE FUNDING.
CARD STAFF EXPECT MOST IF NOT
ALL OF THESE STATIONS WILL ALSO
PARTICIPATE IN THE AVAILABLE
LOW CARBON FUEL STANDARD
PROVISIONS. CARBONELL SAYS FIND
THAT 75% OF THE CURRENTLY OPEN
OR PLANNED FEELING THAT WORK
WOULD BE WITHIN A SIX MINUTE
DRIVE OF A DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY PROVIDING SIMILAR
CONVENIENCE TO HYDROGEN
FUELING. AS TODAY'S GASOLINE
NETWORK FOR THESE COMMUNITIES.
ANALYSIS OF FINER SCALE FIND AT
APPROXIMATELY ONE THIRD OF BOTH
CALIFORNIA'S GENERAL AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY
POPULATIONS. LIVE WITHIN THIS
COMMITTEE CONVENIENCE SIX
MINUTE DRIVE OF AN OPEN OR
PLANNED HYDROGEN STATION.
STATION TECHNOLOGY CAPABILITIES
HAVE EVOLVED SINCE THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM BEGAN IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN. EARLY STATIONS
ARE MOSTLY SMALL WITH THE
ABILITY TO FEEL APPROXIMATELY
FORTY FIVE VEHICLES PER DAY.
EARLY STATIONS ALSO TYPICALLY
INCLUDED ONLY ONE DISPENSER SO
ONLY ABLE TO FEEL A SINGLE
VEHICLE AT A TIME. STATIONS
BEING BUILT TODAY ARE NOW ABLE
TO VIEW AS MANY AS FOUR HUNDRED
VEHICLES IN A DAY AND INCLUDE
DISPENSERS I CAN FEEL UP TO
FOUR INDIVIDUAL VEHICLES
SIMULTANEOUSLY. THE STATION CAN
PROVIDE A MORE POSITIVE
CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE AND ENABLE
IMPROVEMENTS IN MANAGING
STATION OPERATIONS.
CALIFORNIA'S HYDROGEN FUELING
STATIONS SUPPORT PROGRAMS ARE
MAKING SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS
TOWARDS MEETING THE GOALS OF AB
EIGHT AN EXECUTIVE ORDER B.
FORTY EIGHT EIGHTEEN. IN TOTAL
THE CURRENTLY OPEN AND PLANNED
NETWORK INCLUDES NEARLY ONE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY HYDROGEN
FUELING STATIONS. WHEN ALL THE
STATION DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS
ARE COMPLETE CALIFORNIA'S
HYDROGEN FUELING NETWORK WILL
HAVE A SUFFICIENT CAPACITY. TO
SUPPORT A POPULATION OF TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND FUEL
CELL ELECTRIC VEHICLES ON THE
ROAD. THIS PUTS CALIFORNIA'S
HYDROGEN STATION NETWORK
DEVELOPMENT EFFORTS ON TRACK TO
MEET THE ONE HUNDRED STATION
MILESTONE ESTABLISHED IN EIGHTY
EIGHT. DUE TO THE LEGISLATURE
HAS RECENTLY PASSED ONE TIME
FUNDING C. EASY WILL BE ABLE TO
CLOSE A RECENTLY IDENTIFIED
SMALL GAP. TO ACHIEVING THE TWO
HUNDRED STATION TARGET.
HYDROGEN FUELING STATION
NETWORK DEVELOPMENT IN
CALIFORNIA HAS NOW SPENT
SEVERAL YEARS IN MULTIPLE GRANT
SOLICITATIONS WITHIN THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM. THE
FELICITATION SEVEN VANCE THE
HYDROGEN FUELING NETWORK FROM
THE RESEARCH AND DEMONSTRATION
PHASE. THREE PRE COMMERCIAL
TRANSITION AND NOW INTO
COMMERCIAL SCALE. AT THE
NETWORKING INDUSTRY HAS EVOLVED
SO HAVE CARDS ANALYSES OF NEEDS
AND STATION REQUIREMENTS AND
GRANT SOLICITATIONS. INCLUDING
CRITERIA FOR DETERMINING NEW
STATION LOCATIONS. AN ALL STATE
SUPPORT PROGRAMS STATION
DEVELOPER SELECTED LOCATIONS
THEY WISH TO PROPOSE. AND PRIOR
GRANT SOLICITATIONS DAY STOP
LIST THE VERY FIRST HYDROGEN
THAT ESTABLISHED A VERY FIRST
HYDROGEN STATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA. REQUIREMENTS FOR
STATION LOCATION WHERE MORE
PRESCRIPTIVE TO ENSURE THAT
STATIONS WILL BE BUILT IN
APPLICATIONS THAT PROVIDE
CONVENIENT FEELING OPTIONS FOR
THE LARGEST POTENTIAL FUEL CELL
ELECTRIC VEHICLE ADOPTER MARKET.
GIVEN THE GROWTH IN THE STATE'S
HYDROGEN FUELING NETWORK AND A
DESIRE TO FOSTER ADVANCEMENTS
AND ECONOMIES OF SCALE WITHIN
THE HYDROGEN STATION INDUSTRY.
THE LATEST GRANT SOLICITATION
ADOPTED A LESS PRESCRIPTIVE
STRATEGY FOCUSED PRIMARILY ON
STATION CAPACITY. THUS THE
LOCATIONS OF UP TO SIXTY SIX OF
THE STATIONS THAT WILL BE
DEVELOPED THROUGH THE LATEST
ROUND OF CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM FUNDING. HAVE NOT YET
BEEN DETERMINED. LOS STATION
DEVELOPERS ARE FREE TO PROPOSED
STATIONS ACROSS MUCH OF THE
STATE LARGER STATIONS ARE
REQUIRED IN AREAS THAT HAVE
ESTABLISHED AN INITIAL LOSS ON
THAT LOCAL NETWORK. AND ARE
EXPECTED TO HAVE THE LARGEST
LOCAL FUEL CELL ELECTRIC
VEHICLE MARKETS. AT A MULTI
YEAR GRANT PROGRAM STATION
DEVELOPERS WILL IDENTIFY
LOCATIONS IN SUCCESSIVE BATCHES
WITH GUIDANCE PROVIDED BY CARDS
ANALYSIS OF NEEDS FOR FUTURE
NETWORK GROWTH. IT'S A
VALUATION IS BASED ON TOOLS
DEVELOPED A CAR THAT WILL BE
DISCUSSED IN THE FOLLOWING
FLIGHT. THE MAP ON THE RIGHT
SHOWS THE ANALYSIS ACCORDING TO
THIS NEW CAPACITY BASED
STRATEGY AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE SOLICITATION. THE MAP
CATEGORIZES AREAS ACCORDING TO
THE CURRENT LOCAL NETWORK
DEVELOPMENT AND POTENTIAL NEED
FOR HIGH CAPACITY STATIONS.
STATION DEVELOPERS PROPOSING
STATIONS IN AREAS WITH AN
ORANGE COLOR DENOTED CAPACITY
GROWTH ARE ENCOURAGED TO
DEVELOP HIGH CAPACITY STATIONS.
THESE ARE CURRENTLY LOCATED IN
WESTERN LOS ANGELES NEAR IRVINE
AND SAN FRANCISCO AND IN THE
SOUTHEAST PORTION OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREAS NEAR SAN
JOSE MOUNTAIN VIEW PALO ALTO
AND OTHER NEARBY COMMUNITIES.
AS NEWS STATIONS ARE PROPOSED
BY AUTHORITIES TO FUTURE PHASES
OF CONSTRUCTION KARBALA JUSTICE
EVALUATION AND MORE AREAS WILL
BE IDENTIFIED WITH REQUIREMENTS
FOR HIGH CAPACITY STATIONS.
UNDER AB EIGHT THE CARD IS
DIRECTED TO ANNUALLY PROVIDE AN
ANALYSIS OF NEEDS FOR FUTURE
STATION LOCATIONS CONSIDERING
THE TWO METRICS OF COVERAGE AND
CAPACITY. COVERAGE DESCRIBES
THE DEGREE OF CONVENIENT ACCESS
TO HYDROGEN FUELING STATIONS
THAT POTENTIAL FUEL CELL
ELECTRIC VEHICLE DRIVERS HAPPEN
NEIGHBORHOODS ACROSS THE STATE.
CAPACITY ANALYSIS EVALUATES THE
TOTAL FEELING CAPACITY OF
AVAILABLE HYDROGEN FUELING
STATIONS COMPARED TO THE
ESTIMATED LOCAL FUELING DEMAND
A FUTURE FUEL CELL ELECTRIC
VEHICLE DRIVERS. AND TWENTY
FIFTEEN CARD FIRST PUBLISHED
ITS GEOSPATIAL ANALYSIS TOOL
THAT WAS DEVELOPED SPECIFICALLY
TO EVALUATE THE METRICS OF
COVERAGE AND CAPACITY FOR
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
THIS TOOL WAS THEN FURTHER
UPDATE IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND
AGAIN EARLIER THIS YEAR AND HAS
BEEN UTILIZED IN ALL ANNUAL
EVALUATIONS PER ABA PUBLISHED
BY CARD SINCE TWENTY FIFTEEN.
THE TO IDENTIFIED GAPS IN
CAPACITY COVERAGE AND CAPACITY
BY COMPARING THE COVERAGE AND
CAPACITY PROVIDED BY THE OPEN
FUNDED. OPEN UNFUNDED HYDROGEN
FUELING NETWORK. TO AN
EVALUATION OF FUEL CELL
ELECTRIC VEHICLE ADOPTER MARKET.
IN ALICE'S ALSO COMPARES
NETWORK COVERAGE TO LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. THE TOOL
IDENTIFIES AREAS WHERE NEW
STATIONS ARE MOST NEEDED BY
FINDING THE LARGEST
MISALIGNMENT BETWEEN THE FUEL
CELL ADOPTER MARKET NEEDS AND
THE COVERAGE AND CAPACITY
PROVIDED BY THE HYDROGEN
FUELING NETWORK. THE MAP ON THE
RIGHT EXPLAINS CARDS MOST
RECENT DRAFT EVALUATION OF
COVERAGE ACCOUNTING FOR ALL
STATIONS KNOWN TO BE CURRENTLY
OPEN AND UNDER DEVELOPMENT OR
PLANNED FOR FUTURE DEVELOPMENT.
THE TANK OUTLINED IN THE FIGURE
IDENTIFIED THE AREAS WHERE
ADDITIONAL STATIONS ARE
CURRENTLY MOST NEEDED IN ORDER
TO ESTABLISH OR FURTHER ENHANCE
FEELING ACCESS. FOR POTENTIAL
FUEL CELL ELECTRIC VEHICLE
DOCTORS. THIS LATEST ANALYSIS
FROM CARD STAFF HIGHLIGHTS THAT
THERE CONTINUES TO BE
OPPORTUNITY FOR EXPANDED
NETWORK GROWTH IN PARTS OF SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA LOS ANGELES
AND ORANGE COUNTY FOR HYDROGEN
STATIONS CURRENTLY OPERATE. IN
ADDITION PRIORITIES EXIST IN
AREAS AND OTHER MARKETS ACROSS
THE STATE INCLUDING SANJAY SAN
DIEGO THE CENTRAL COAST THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY RIVERSIDE AND
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTIES IN THE
NORTHERN PART OF THE STATE.
TODAY THREE MODELS ARE
AVAILABLE WHICH ARE SHOWN
THROUGHOUT THE VEHICLES ARE
AVAILABLE WHICH ARE SHOWN ON
THE SLIDE. THESE INCLUDE THE
TOYOTA MIRAI HONDA CLARITY AND
HYUNDAI NEXT SO. ALTHOUGH HONDA
WILL STOP SELLING THE CLARITY
AT THE END OF THIS MODEL YEAR
THEY CONTINUE DEVELOPMENT ON
THE NEXT FUEL CELL ELECTRIC
VEHICLE MODEL FOR FUTURE
RELEASE. AT LEAST TWO OTHER
AUTO MANUFACTURERS HAVE
RECENTLY ANNOUNCED INTENT TO
DEVELOP AND MARKET THEIR OWN
FUEL CELL ELECTRIC EHICLE.
BASED ON DATA PROVIDED BY THE
ENERGY COMMISSION SENT
DASHBOARD THERE WERE
APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY ONE
HUNDRED FUEL CELL ELECTRIC
VEHICLES DRIVING ON
CALIFORNIA'S ROADS BY THE END
OF TWENTY TWENTY. BASED ON THE
LATEST SURVEY ABOUT A
MANUFACTURER PLANS FOR FUTURE
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE SALES IN
CALIFORNIA THE IN STATE FUEL
CELL ELECTRIC VEHICLE
POPULATION IS PROJECTED TO
CONTINUE TO GROW. AND
ACCELERATE DEPLOYMENT IN THE
NEAR TERM. SURVEY RESULTS
INDICATE THIRTY ONE THOUSAND
FUEL CELL ELECTRIC VEHICLES
COULD BE ON THE ROAD IN TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR AND SIXTY ONE
THOUSAND AND TWENTY TWENTY
SEVEN. THE RECENT COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAD A
NOTICEABLE ACT IMPACT ON FUEL
CELL ELECTRIC VEHICLE SALES BUT
INDUSTRY PROVIDED SALES DATA
THROUGH THE FIRST FIVE MONTHS
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE. INDICATE
THAT SALES HAVE BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVES. THE
OTHER DAY IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
ARE ARE ALREADY 83% OF SALES
FOR ALL OF TWENTY NINETEEN. THE
FIRST QUARTER OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WAS ALSO THE BEST SELLING
QUARTER SINCE INDUSTRY TRACKING
BEGAN IN TWENTY TWELVE.
HYDROGEN IS A VERSATILE FUEL
CHOICE FOR TRANSPORTATION WITH
MANY POSSIBLE PRODUCTION
PATHWAYS FROM MULTIPLE
FEEDSTOCKS AND PROVIDING ZERO
TAILPIPE EMISSIONS WHEN PAIRED
WITH THE FUEL CELL. HOWEVER THE
FULL LIFE CYCLE OF HYDROGEN
FUEL PRODUCTION DISTRIBUTION
AND DISPENSING IS JUST AS
IMPORTANT AS A FINAL AND USE.
CALIFORNIA POLICIES AND
PROGRAMS HAVE LONG RECOGNIZED
THE IMPORTANCE OF RENEWABLE AND
LOW CARBON PRODUCTION. AND
DISTRIBUTION PATHWAYS IN ORDER
TO MAXIMIZE EMISSIONS BENEFIT
OFFERED BY HYDROGEN FUEL. BOB
GLOBAL HYDROGEN PRODUCTION IS
PROBABLY GENERATED FROM FOSSIL
FUEL FEEDSTOCKS TYPICALLY
NATURAL GAS. TO HYDROGEN
DISPENSING CALIFORNIA'S
HYDROGEN FUELING NETWORK IS
STARKLY DIFFERENT. AND STATE
POLICY REQUIRES ANY HYDROGEN
FUELING STATION RECEIVING STATE
FUNDS MUST DISPENSE AT LEAST
THIRTY THREE POINT 3% OF ITS
HYDROGEN FROM SORT. OF HIS THAT
GENERATE THAT HYDROGEN USING
RENEWABLE FEEDSTOCKS. IN TWENTY
NINETEEN CHANGES TO LOW CARBON
FUEL STANDARD THE NEW CAPACITY
BASED CREDIT ACCREDITING
PROVISION FOR HYDROGEN FUEL
STATIONS. INCLUDED A NEW AND
HIGHER MINIMUM REQUIREMENT OF
40% RENEWABLE CONTENT AND A
MAXIMUM CARBON INTENSITY. THE
SAME RENEWABLE REQUIREMENT WAS
INCORPORATED INTO THE ENERGY
COMMISSION'S LATEST GRANT
FUNDING SOLICITATION. ALL NEW
HYDROGEN STATIONS RESULTING
FROM THE STATE'S SUPPORT
PROGRAMS WILL BE REQUIRED TO
MEET THIS 40% RENEWABLE CONTENT
MINIMUM ON AVERAGE. IN PRACTICE
CALIFORNIA'S HYDROGEN FUELING
NETWORK AT RECENTLY OPERATED
WITH MUCH HIGHER RENEWABLE
CONTENT. BASED ON DATA
AVAILABLE THROUGH THE LOW
CARBON FUEL STANDARD CARD STAFF
ESTIMATE THAT IN TWENTY TWENTY
AND SO FAR IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
MOST OF CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA'S
HYDROGEN FUELING NETWORK HAS
DISPENSED HYDROGEN ATTY
SUSTAINED 90% RENEWABLE
CONTENT. STATION OPERATORS HAVE
SHARED THAT THIS HIGH USE OF
RENEWABLES IS NOT YET BASED ON
LONG TERM CONTRACTS SO THE
CONTINUATION OF SUCH HIGH
RENEWABLE IMPLEMENTATION INTO
THE FUTURE IS CURRENTLY
UNCERTAIN. HOWEVER THIS IS A
POSITIVE INDICATION THAT WOULD
NORMALLY BASED HYDROGEN FUEL
CAN BE A VIABLE COMPONENT OF
THE STATE'S ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE STRATEGY. DR ALMOST
HYDROGEN FUEL INCLUDING REAL
HEARTY BELIEVES THAT ONE
MINUTE. CLOSE ONE MINUTE TO
CLOSE PLEASE. OKAY THANK YOU.
SOME STATIONS DO HAVE ONSITE
PRODUCTION IMAGES ON THE RIGHT
ARE FROM THE COLOCATED LIGHT
DUTY AND BUS HYDROGEN FUELING
STATION AC TRANSIT AND
EMERYVILLE. THE CANOPY IN THE
IMAGE INTEGRATE SORT OF SOLAR
PHOTOVOLTAIC CELLS WHICH
PROVIDES ENERGY. RENEWABLE
ELECTRICITY FOR HYDROGEN
FUELING ONSITE. MUCH OF THE
FOCUS IN CALIFORNIA SUPPORT
PROGRAMS FOR HYDROGEN STATION
DEVELOPMENT HAS BEEN BUILT
AROUND ACHIEVING CERTAIN
TARGETS FOR COUNTS OF HYDROGEN
FUELING STATIONS. THIS IS
IMPORTANT AND EARLY MARKET
DEVELOPMENT AS DURING THE
NETWORK TO A CERTAIN SIZE
SUPPORTS INITIAL CUSTOMER
ADOPTION OF FUEL CELL ELECTRIC
VEHICLES. HOWEVER THE NETWORK
MATURES ADDITIONAL
CONSIDERATIONS ESPECIALLY
ECONOMIC PERFORMANCE PLAY MORE
VITAL ROLE IN ADDITION TO
NUMBERS OF STATIONS AB EIGHT
ALSO REFERENCES THE CONCEPT THE
FINANCIAL SELF SUFFICIENCY.
THAT IS THE ABILITY OF THE
HYDROGEN FUELING NETWORK TO
OPERATE AND CONTINUE TO GROW AS
NEEDED WITHOUT ADDITIONAL STATE
SUPPORT. OUR STAFF HAVE
RECENTLY PUBLISHED A DRAFT
REPORT BASED ON AN ECONOMIC
ANALYSIS OF SEVERAL SCENARIOS
FOR FUTURE HYDROGEN FUELING
STATION NETWORK DEVELOPMENT.
THE DRAFT REPORT EVALUATES
POTENTIAL FUTURE SCENARIOS OF
STATION NETWORK GROWTH VEHICLE
DEPLOYMENT AND DEVELOPMENTS AND
STATION ECONOMICS TO ASSESS THE
CONDITIONS THAT LEAD TO THE
EMERGENCE OF A SELF SUFFICIENT
HYDROGEN FUELING NETWORK. WE
ARE WORKING WITH EASY TO
CORPORATE SOME OF THESE
FINDINGS INTO THE AB EIGHT
REPORT. FINALLY EVEN WITH THE
PROGRESS MADE TO DATE IN
CALIFORNIA CHALLENGES REMAIN TO
DEVELOPING A SELF SUFFICIENT
HYDROGEN FUELING NETWORK
PRIMARILY FOR FACTORS OTHER
THAN GROWING THE NUMBER OF
HYDROGEN FUELING STATIONS.
THAT'S BECAUSE STATIONS ARE
ONLY PART OF THE FUEL CELL
VEHICLE ECOSYSTEM WE OFTEN GET
CALLS CUSTOMERS. RELIABLE FUEL
SUPPLY AND LOWER FUEL COSTS. IN
ORDER FOR THE ECOSYSTEM TO
BECOME SUSTAINABLE WE NEED.
SUFFICIENT THROUGHPUT AND USAGE
OF THE HYDROGEN FUELING
STATIONS SO THEY BECOME
PROFITABLE. ON THIS FIGHT ALSO
OUTLINES A FEW. OF THE
CHALLENGES SPECIFICALLY THAT WE
HAVE SEEN THROUGH OUR
EVALUATION. THANK YOU MISTER
MARTINEZ SIMPLY STAY WITH US SO
WE CAN- HAVE SOME QUESTIONS.
AND ANSWERS. AFTER ALL THE
PANELISTS. AND NEXT ON OUR
PANEL IS LESLIE MOORE DIRECTOR
OF FACILITIES AND FLEETS AT THE
AMERICAN RED CROSS. LESLIE MORE
YOU'VE GOT TO FLOOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR AND
TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS I JUST
WANTED TO THANK YOU FOR LETTING
US HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE THE EXPERIENCE OF THE
AMERICAN RED CROSS HAS HAPPENED
ZERO EMISSION HYDROGEN FUEL
CELL VEHICLES- AS YOU SAID MY
NAME IS LESLIE MAHER OF THE
STATE FACILITIES DIRECTOR FOR
THE AMERICAN RED CROSS LOS
ANGELES REGION- THE RED CROSS
IS SO PLEASED TO BE TESTING
THIS TECHNOLOGY. I'M TO HELP
REDUCE THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE GLOBALLY WE CONSIDER
CLIMATE CHANGE TO BE A
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS EVERY DAY
WE SEE THE HEARTBREAK OF
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES TRYING
TO COPE WITH MORE INTENSE
STORMS HEAVIER RAINFALL HIGHER
TEMPERATURES. STRONG HURRICANES
AND ESPECIALLY HERE WILDFIRES.
TO GIVE YOU SOME BACKGROUND
LATE LAST YEAR THE RED CROSS
LOS ANGELES KICKED OFF ITS
FIRST EVER ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE PILOT PROGRAM AFTER
RECEIVING A DONATION OF FIVE
HYDROGEN FUEL CELL VEHICLES WE
RECEIVED AS DONATION FROM A
PARTNER NONPROFIT ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE NOW WORKING WITH
TOYOTA. THEY'RE OBVIOUSLY TO
ENTERPRISE- AND THE VEHICLES
HAVE BEEN NOW IN USE FOR ABOUT
EIGHT MONTHS. WE'VE BEEN
SUPPORTING DISASTERS AND
BIOMEDICAL OPERATIONS. COMBINED
WE HAVE COVERED ALMOST SEVEN
THOUSAND MILES AND HAVE ALREADY
REDUCED FLEET EMISSIONS BY
APPROXIMATELY TWO TONS OF
CARBON DIOXIDE. WE'RE SO PROUD
OF THAT NUMBER IN ADDITION TO
REDUCING THE IMPACT OF CLIMATE
CHANGE WE'RE JUST SO HAPPY TO
HELP REDUCE HARMFUL AIR
POLLUTION FROM THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR. WHICH
DIRECTLY IMPACTS PUBLIC HEALTH.
THE REASONS WHY THE FUEL CELL
VEHICLES ARE SUCH A GOOD FIT
FOR RED CROSS- ARE AS FOLLOWS.
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES HELP
SUPPORT OUR SUSTAINABILITY
GOALS TO RELATIVE TO AIR
QUALITY AND CLIMATE CHANGE.
THESE VEHICLES SPECIFICALLY
OFFER BASS REVEALING IT TAKES
ABOUT FIVE MINUTES AS YOU KNOW
RED CROSSERS NEVER KNOW WHEN
THEY'LL BE ABLE TO HELP WHEN
THEY HAVE TO RESPOND TO
EMERGENCIES SO WE NEED ACCESS
TO FLEET VEHICLES WITH MINIMAL
FEELING ARE CHARGING DOWNTIME.
SO IF YOU ALSO ATTRIBUTE GOALS
OFFER A LONG RANGE. THE RESPOND
AS EVER KNOW WHEN THEY'LL HAVE
TO GO TO AN EMERGENCY AND
WHETHER THERE WILL BE ACCESS TO
FUELING OR CHARGING IN THE
FIELD- AND IN ADDITION. THE
FEEL SOLID CRITICAL HAVE
INTENTIONAL TO OFFER STATIONARY
BACKUP POWER FROM THE ACTUAL
VEHICLE. ZERO EMISSION BACKUP
POWER ALLOWS THEM TO SUPPORT
VITAL ACTIVITIES IN THE FIELD
WITHOUT NOISE OR THE EMISSIONS
OF THE TRADITIONAL DIESEL
GENERATOR. SINCE LAUNCHING THIS
PROGRAM THE RED CROSS DRIVERS
HAVE GIVEN US VERY POSITIVE
FEEDBACK ABOUT THE VEHICLES
THEMSELVES. AND THE DRIVING
EXPERIENCE. THE VEHICLES ARE IN
EXCELLENT CONDITION AND THEY
HANDLE REALLY WELL AND LA
TRAFFIC. THE ABILITY TO DRIVE
IN THE HOV LANE MAKES A
CRITICAL DIFFERENCE OPERATIONS
DURING DISASTERS MOBILE BLOOD
DRIVES AND DELIVERIES OF THE
BLOOD PRODUCTS. OUR BIGGEST
CHALLENGE I WILL SHARE HAS BEEN
ACCESS TO FUELING STATIONS AND
THE CONSISTENCY OF THE HYDROGEN
FUEL SUPPLY. OUR REGION SERVICE
MORE THAN ONE QUARTER OF THE
POPULATION OF CALIFORNIA
SPENDING LOS ANGELES COUNTY WE
HAVE OFFICES FROM LONG BEACH TO
PALMDALE. DOWNTOWN ATLANTA
PRAMANA THE WHOLE COUNTY. WILL
BE STRATEGICALLY PLACED THE
VEHICLES AT OUR FACILITIES NEAR
NEAREST TO THE FILLING STATIONS.
SOMETIMES A STATIONS SOME OF
THEM ONLY HAVE ONE TIME. IF THE
SESSION GOES DOWN DUE TO A
DISPENSER OR MECHANICAL ISSUE
THERE'S NO ALTERNATE CONFUSE.
IF THE VEHICLE HAPPENS TO BE
LOW ON FUEL IT HAS TO SIT AT
THE STATION UNTIL IT OPENS.
BECAUSE THE NEAREST ONE COULD
BE MILES AWAY. SO OUR FLEET
TEAM INTERNALLY HAS PROTOCOLS
TO CHECK THE FUEL STATUS OUT
WHICH IS AN APP THAT YOU CAN
DOWNLOAD ON YOUR PHONE. THAT
GIVES YOU THE STATION STATUS
PRIOR TO FUELING. AND TODAY WE
ALSO HAVE A PROTOCOL TO
IDENTIFY A BACKUP FUELING
STATION JUST IN CASE THE FIRST
ONE HAPPENED TO BE DOWN. OR OUT
OF FUEL BY THE TIME WE ARRIVED.
I CAN SHARE THAT PERSONALLY
I'VE SEEN MANY HUNDREDS OF
VEHICLES STRANDED AT FILLING
STATIONS WAITING FOR THEM TOREPLENISH YOU'LL OR DISPENSER
PROBLEM. THE RED CROSS FLEET
TEAM HAS HAD TO USE GAS
VEHICLES IN THE FLEET WHILE THE
HYDROGEN ONE'S WAIT WAIT
FEELING. WHICH IS NOT IDEAL FOR
DISASTER RESPONSE- THE VEHICLES
HAVE TO BE READY TO GO AT A
MOMENT'S NOTICE. SO TO SUM UP.
THE FUEL CELL ELECTRIC VEHICLES
BRINGING BENEFITS TO THE RED
CROSS MISSION. TO SUSTAIN THESE
VEHICLES AND THEIR BENEFITS IN
THE LONG TERM WE WOULD URGE THE
STATE TO EMBARK MORE FEELING
STATIONS. AND HAVE MORE
CONSISTENT FUEL REPLENISHMENT.
IF THE HYDROGEN FUEL STATIONS
WERE SET UP WITH IT AND MORE
LOCATIONS AND WE'RE JUST A BIT
MORE RELIABLE. WITH FEELING I
WOULD NOT HESITATE TO RECOMMEND
MORE FUEL CELL ELECTRIC
VEHICLES FOR THE RED CROSS
FLEET. SO CLOSING I JUST WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY. I'M
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU- THIS
MORE- IF YOU'LL PLEASE STAND BY
AND WE'LL GET TO. LATER WHEN WE
GET ALL THE PANELISTS-
COMPLETED WITH THEIR TESTIMONY
NEXT WE HAVE THE BALL SIMON
DIRECTOR OF ECO ECO COMPLIANCE
AND RESEARCH AT HONDA MOTOR
COMPANY. AT ANY TIME AND YOU'VE
GOT TO FLOOR. THANK YOU SIR AND
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE ON THE
COMMITTEE FOR GIVING US TIME
TODAY I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
EVERYONE CAN SEE MY SCREEN. YES
THAT'S CORRECT GREAT SO AGAIN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO TALK TODAY ABOUT
HYDROGEN FUEL CELLS AND SELL
AND SHARE OUR EXPERIENCE IN
THE- LAKE TO THE SEGMENT. I'M
SO SORRY I WAS JUST A REALLY
BRIEF INTRODUCTION A HYUNDAI-
SOME YOU MAY KNOW WE ARE THE
SIX LARGEST GLOBAL AUTOMOTIVE.
ARE MANUFACTURED BY BRAND. MORE
PROBLEMS SIMPLY OVER TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE IN THE U.
S. NATIONALLY WHEN YOU INCLUDE
OUR DEALERS. WE PROUD THAT OUR
HOME BASES RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. OUR NORTH AMERICAN
HEADQUARTERS WHERE I'M TALKING
FROM TODAY'S IN FOUNTAIN
VALLEY. WE HAVE A DESIGN
PRESENTS A IRVINE WE HAVE
ENGINEERING IN CHINO AND WE
HAVE OUR VEHICLE PROVING
GROUNDS OF THE DUCKS DESERT IN
CALIFORNIA CITY. SO WE'RE
CONTRAST IN CALIFORNIA. AND
WE'RE ACUTELY AWARE OF THE
ISSUES THAT CALIFORNIA'S FACING
AS WE TRANSITION OF ZERO
QUESTIONS- WE'RE HAPPY TO
REPORT WE HAVE HAD A RECORD
YEAR FOR HYUNDAI DELIVERING
OVER FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
VEHICLES THROUGH THE FIRST HALF
OF THE YEAR. AND WE THINK A LOT
OF THAT SUCCESS IS DUE TO OUR
GROWING ELECTRIFIED LINEUP WE
HAVE TWELVE MODELS TODAY. AND
THAT'S GOING TO GROW TO OVER
TWENTY AND JUST A FEW YEARS. SO
IF YOU LOOK AT OUR PRODUCTS OUR
PAST PRESENT- WE REALLY DO
BELIEVE- AND HISTORY OF
DEVELOPING A RANGE OF
ELECTRIFIED SOLUTIONS. TO MEET
CUSTOMER NEEDS IN OTHER WORDS
MORE THAN ONE TECHNOLOGY WITH
HYBRIDS. BATTERY ELECTRICS AND
OF COURSE FUEL CELLS AND AS YOU
CAN SEE FROM THE IMAGES. THESE
ARE ACROSS ALL SEGMENTS NOT
JUST LIGHT DUTY NOT JUST
PASSENGER CARS. CARS SUVS
TRUCKS BUSES HEAVY DUTY
COMMERCIAL. SO REALLY WE
BELIEVE IN CUSTOMER CHOICE AND
A WIDE. VARIETY OF ELECTRIFIED
SOLUTIONS AND WE THINK THAT'S
THE RIGHT PATH TOWARDS ZERO
EMISSIONS. BUT OF COURSE WE
REALLY VALUE HYDROGEN AND FUEL
CELL AND ITS POTENTIAL AND THE
QUESTION IS WHY WHY ARE WE SO
BULLISH ON HYDROGEN. WELL AS I
MENTIONED TECHNOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY IS VERY IMPORTANT FOR
US SENATE SOME OF THE
PRESENTERS OF START EARLIER-
IT'S IMPORTANT NOT TO RELY ON
ONE SINGLE TECHNOLOGY AS WE
PURSUE A ZERO EMISSION
PORTFOLIO. AND WE THINK FUEL
CELLS CAN REALLY HELP DIVERSIFY
OUR PORTFOLIO. CUSTOMER CHOICE
OBVIOUSLY IS ALWAYS IMPORTANT
TO US AND- THE BENEFIT OF- IN
THE LIGHT DUTY SECTOR OF THE
HYDROGEN IS THE SIMILAR
FEELING. EXPERIENCE THAT PEOPLE
ARE USED TO WITH GAS VEHICLES
OF COURSE WITHOUT THE EMISSIONS
AND YOU SEE THE IMAGE ON THE
TOP OF. OF OUR NEXT SO. I
DON'T- HUNDRED SHIELD STATION.
AND THEN THE- THE PROMISE OF
MULTIMODAL TRANSPORTATION
APPLICATIONS FOR FUEL CELLS AND
HYDROGEN. AND WE REALLY BELIEVE
HYDROGEN IS A GREAT SOLUTION
BEYOND PASSENGER CARS FOR HEAVY
DUTY. CARGO AIR SHIPPING SO
REALLY DEVELOPING THIS
ECOSYSTEM. A LOT OF SYNERGIES
CAN COME OUT OF IT AND REALLY
BENEFIT HYDROGEN AND FUEL CELL
ADVANCEMENT OVERALL. SO HERE
HYDROGEN AT HYUNDAI WE- LAUNCH
START EACH TO BRAND IT'S A
PROPERLY NAMES REPRESENTS OUR
COMMITMENT TO HYDROGEN AND FUEL
CELLS AND REALLY IS. A
REPRESENTATION OF OUR GOAL OF
BROAD APPLICATION OF OUR FUEL
CELL SYSTEM. OR ACTIVELY
IMPROVING OUR SYSTEM ARE RIGHT
NOW WORKING ON THE NEXT
GENERATION WHICH HAVE ENHANCED
PERFORMANCE AND DURABILITY. I
DON'T GO LONG TERM BY TWENTY
THIRTY IS PRODUCED SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND OF THESE
SYSTEMS. GLOBALLY AND SELL
EVERY YEAR. AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER WE DO SEE BOAD
APPLICATION BEYOND THE LIGHT
DUTY SPACE- AND HEAVY DUTY
COMMERCIAL AIR OF THE IMAGE ON
THE SLIDE IN THE MIDDLE IS OUR
HEAVY DUTY ACCION'S FUEL CELL.
TRUCK WHICH IS- ACTIVELY DOING
COMMERCIAL USED IN EUROPE AND
WE- LITERALLY JUST ANNOUNCED
YESTERDAY WE'RE GONNA BE DOING
PROJECTS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
STARTING NEXT MONTH. WITH THIS
TRUCK SO WE'RE VERY EXCITED
ABOUT THAT. BUT I KNOW WE ARE
FOCUSED ON LIGHT DUTY PASSENGER
CARS AND HERE IN CALIFORNIA AS
WAS MENTIONED IN OTHER
PRESENTATIONS WE ARE SELLING.
THE NEXT SO WHICH IS THE
WORLD'S FIRST DEDICATED
HYDROGEN POWERED SUV. IT'S BEEN
ON SALE SINCE TWENTY EIGHTEEN-
IT'S GOT RANGE OF UP TO THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY MILES SO REALLY
INCREDIBLE RANGE AND- AS I
MENTIONED JUST FIVE MINUTES
THREE FEEL SO VERY NORMAL
FEELING EXPERIENCE THAT PEOPLE
ARE USED TO. AND- IF YOU'RE
DRIVING NEXT TO YOUR REALIZE IT
DRIVES JUST LIKE ANY OTHER
VEHICLE ON THE ROAD- EXCEPT NO
EMISSIONS IT HAS ADVANCED
SAFETY AND TECHNOLOGY AND IT
REALLY IS- SOMETHING WE'RE
PROUD OF IS THE FIRST US UP. SO
WE REALLY THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO UNDERSTAND AS WE LOOK TO
EXPAND- HYDROGEN AND LIKE TO
THE FUEL CELLS. WHAT ARE THE
PRIORITY OF OUR CUSTOMERS OF
THE OR THE CUSTOMERS
CONSIDERING THIS TECHNOLOGY. A
LOT OF WAYS- WHAT CUSTOMERS
CONSIDER IS AS YOU WOULD EXPECT
SOME OF THE OTHER ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE CUSTOMERS LIKE BETH
CUSTOMERS. THEY CARE ABOUT
EFFICIENCY. RANGE AND OF COURSE
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS AND YOU
SEE SOME OF THAT- HIGHLIGHTED
IN BLUE ON THE LEFT. WHERE THE
FUEL CELL SHOPPERS ARE UNIQUE
IS A FOCUS ON CONVENTIONAL
FEELING AS I MENTIONED AND
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THIS IS
REALLY SOMETHING VERY IMPORTANT
THAT WE NEED TO BUILD OUT
BECAUSE AGAIN THEY LIKE THE
FACT THAT. THESE VEHICLES FUEL
THE SAME WAY THAT THEY'RE USED
TO BUT THEY NEED TO MAKE SURE
THERE'S ENOUGH FUELING STATIONS
AVAILABLE- AND THAT'S REALLY
WHAT WE SEE IS AS CRITICAL TO
CONSIDERATION AND CAN BE A TOP
BARRIER. IF WE DON'T BUILD OUT
THE INFRASTRUCTURE. WE TALK TO
OUR NEXT SO OWNERS OBVIOUSLY-
WE TRY TO GET AS MUCH FEEDBACK
AS POSSIBLE WE'RE HAPPY TO
REPORT. NEXT OWNERS DO LOVE
THEIR CAR- FOR SOME OF THE
TRADITIONAL REASONS PEOPLE MAY
LOVE THEIR CARS THE DESIGN THE
DRIVING EXPERIENCE. I MENTIONED
THE RANGE IS IMPORTANT TO US
HAVE CUSTOMERS OF UP TO THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY MILES. BUT THEY
REALLY LOVE IT BECAUSE IT
REPRESENTS A PARENT EARLY
ADOPTER THEY HAVE SOMETHING
SPECIAL IS UNIQUE THEY REALLY
EMBRACE THIS TECHNOLOGY- AND
THEY NOT ONLY ARE THEY LIKELY
TO PURCHASE ANOTHER NEXT SO BUT
THERE ARE ALSO LIKELY TO.
RECOMMEND THE NEXT. ON THE FLIP
SIDE THOUGH WHAT THEY DON'T LOG
IN WHAT WE'RE HEARING. A LOT
FROM SOME OF OUR CUSTOMERS MOST
RECENTLY IS THAT ALL OF THE
FUELING EXPERIENCE. AND THERE'S
A LOT OF INFORMATION ON THE
SLIDE BUT I THINK- SOME OF THE
IMAGES REALLY CONVEY. THE POINT
DAMAGE ON THE RIGHT. IS A LINE
OF FUEL CELL VEHICLES TAKEN- I
THINK MAYBE IN TWENTY NINETEEN.
WAITING TO RE FUEL SO YOU
REALLY DON'T WANT TO SEE THAT
YOU DON'T WANT CUSTOMERS. TO
HAVE TO WAIT A LONG TIME. TO
GET FUEL FOR THEIR CARS. SO
REALLY- ON A HIGH LEVEL- SOME
OF THE KEY POINTS OF IT
EXPERIENCING. OFTEN RELIABILITY
ISSUES AND DOWNTIME DAMAGE ON
THE LOWER RIGHT IS TAKEN JUST
LAST WEEK. WHEN THE FUEL CELL
PARTNERSHIP'S WEBSITE AND YOU
SEE THE RED- THE RED SQUARES
AND THAT INDICATES SOME OF THE
STATIONS ARE DOWN FOR WHATEVER
REASON. SO THAT'S SOMETHING
CUSTOMERS HAVE BEEN
EXPERIENCING- OBVIOUSLY WE TALK
ABOUT INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE
LIMITED NUMBER STATION SO THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT'S CRITICAL TO
EXPAND. AND EVEN ISSUES WITH
THE PUMP THEMSELVES OF THE IF
THE STATION IS WORKING AND
THERE IS FUEL- YES SOME
TECHNICAL ISSUES AND HOW TO
FUEL THE PUMPS FREEZING. SO
IT'S REALLY BROUGHT ABOUT SOME
INTERESTING BUYER BEHAVIOR THE
BUYERS REALLY NEED TO- FEEL SO
DRIVERS REALLY NEED TO PLAN THE
ROUTES CAREFULLY. AND EVEN GO
TO- STATIONS WHEN THEY HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF FUEL LEFT
A HUNDRED MILES OR MORE. JUST
IF THEY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
FEEL UP THEY WILL JUST TO-
HOPEFULLY THE VOID THE
SITUATION OF. OF NOT HAVING
FUEL THEY'LL- SO- IN SOME REAL
CLOSE WITH SOLUTIONS FOR THE
CONSIDERATION AND- HERE HYUNDAI
WE DO REALIZE- TO ADVANCED FUEL
CELL AND HYDROGEN WHICH WERE
FIRMLY BEHIND AS THE TECHNOLOGY
AS A COMPANY. WE REALIZE THIS
NEEDS TO BE A COMBINED EFFORT
BOTH FROM THE PRIVATE SIDE AND
PUBLIC SIDE. AND ON OUR PART ON
THE PRIVATE SIDE WE ARE
ACTIVELY INVESTIGATING
PARTNERSHIPS. TO DEVELOP THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE WE THINK IT'S
CRITICAL. I'M WE'RE WE'RE
PURSUING PARTNERSHIPS WITH IN
CALIFORNIA EVEN OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIANS WE HOPE- TO
SPREAD- THE DOBSON OF FUEL CELL
AND HYDROGEN EVEN OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA VENTRALLY. AND
OBVIOUSLY OUR CUSTOMERS ARE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT SO WE WANT
TO SUPPORT THEM IN THIS
TRANSITIONAL TIME SO. ANYWAY
THAT WE CAN ASSIST OUR
CUSTOMERS WERE CHALLENGED. WITH
THE CURRENT INFRASTRUCTURE
UNTIL SUPPLY. WE FIND WAYS TO
DO THAT. ON THE SIDE WE DO
PROPOSE SOME SOLUTIONS FOR
CONSIDERATION. I'M OBVIOUSLY
LONG TERM DEDICATED FUNDING FOR
HYDROGEN STATIONS WITH. THE
GOAL OF AS MANY AS A THOUSAND
STATIONS IN OPERATION BY TWENTY
THIRTY AND WE KNOW THIS IS. AN
AMBITIOUS GOAL REALLY THINK
HAVING A HUGE- REALLY- ROBUST
INFRASTRUCTURE WILL.
EXPONENTIALLY INCREASE THE- THE
FINAL FUEL CELLS ON THE ROAD.
OBVIOUSLY ONE FUEL CELLS TO BE
ELIGIBLE LONG TERM FOR- ANY
STATE INCENTIVES THAT ARE
OFFERED TO OTHER- ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES. AND EVEN
CONSIDERATION OF TAX INCENTIVES
FOR- GASOLINE STATION OPERATORS
TO CONVERT THEIR CURRENT
STATIONS TWO HUNDRED. AND
FINALLY I THINK THIS WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER OF THE NOTION
OF FUEL SUBSIDIES TO ACHIEVE
PRICE PARITY HYDROGEN. IT IS
MORE EXPENSIVE THAN GASOLINE SO
WE THINK IF THERE'S A LEVEL-
PARITY WITH GASOLINE THIS WILL
GET A LOT OF- CONSUMERS
INTERESTED IN HYDROGEN WITH THE
RIGHT STRUCTURE. SO AGAIN-
SUBMIT SOLUTIONS FIRST
CONSIDERATION- WE WOULD LOVE TO
DISCUSS THIS FURTHER AND- I
JUST WANT TO THANK- COMMITTEE
INSIDER FOR TIME TODAY FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OUT OF SERVICE
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND PLEASE STAND
BY. FOR ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS-
WHEN THE LAST SPEAKER. COMES ON
THE AIR- AND NEXT WE WILL HEAR
FROM- LOW ROCHA- MR VICTOR
ROCHE'S CEO AND PRESIDENT AND
CO FOUNDER. TOTAL
TRANSPORTATION SERVICES MR LOW
ROSA YOU HAVE THE FLOOR WE HAD
TEN MINUTES. THANK YOU SATURDAY
NIGHT AND I THINK COMMITTEE FOR
ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY TODAY. I
THINK THE MOST THAT I CAN
CONTRIBUTE IT IS BY TELLING THE
T. T. SI STORY. I THINK. LET ME
START OUT BY SAYING THAT
ALTHOUGH A LOT OF CONSTRUCTION
IS BEGINNING TO LIGHT DUTY WE
ARE 1100% HEAVY DUTY USE. WE
SERVICE SUPPORTS IN NOT ONLY
CALIFORNIA BUT THROUGHOUT THE
UNITED STATES WERE IN SEATTLE
WHERE IN NEW JERSEY WHERE IT'S
JUST OUT OF GEORGIA WERE
CHICAGO. A WIN SEATTLE TACOMA.
AND A COMMON SCHEME MOST COURTS
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES IS
THAT WERE BASED IN. GENERALLY
THE INNER CITY GENERALLY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY IT'S-
SO THEY NEED TO GET TO ZERO
EMISSIONS IS A CENTRAL- PTS I
STARTED ITS JOURNEY BACK THAT
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT WHEN THE
PORTS OF LONG BEACH AND LOS
ANGELES. FIRST INTRODUCED THE
CLEAN AIR ACTION PROGRAM WE
STARTED TO DO A LOT OF INTERNAL
INVESTIGATION INTO EXACTLY
WHERE THIS WHERE THIS WOULD
LEAD. AND WE DETERMINED THAT
THE GULF COAST REGION TEN YOU
TO MOVE UNTIL WE WERE ADIZERO
MISSION. SO WE MADE A CORPORATE
DECISION TO GO TO ZERO EMISSION
WE'RE NOT ONLY GOING TO ZERO
EMISSION IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE
HE PLANNED TO DO THIS ON A
NATIONAL BASIS. IN CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY WE ARE ALMOST 1100%
OUT OF DIESEL. OUR JOURNEY THE
LAST. ELEVEN OR TWELVE YEARS
HAS BEEN MAJORLY. AS A
CONVERSION INTO NATURAL GAS. WE
HAVE HEAVILY EACH WE HAVE
HEAVILY EXPERIMENTED WITH.
BATTERY ELECTRIC WITH FUEL AND
WITH FUEL CELL AS WELL. WE HAVE
A LOT OF CONCERNS ABOUT ALL THE
DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGIES BECAUSE-
IT'S BEEN A VERY VERY BY BEING
VERY VERY RANGY GRINDING ROAD
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO THE
USE AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES-
WON'T. OUR EXPERIENCE WITH
NATURAL GAS IS THAT IT TOOK US
TEN YEARS AND FIVE ITERATIONS
OF AN ENGINE TO GET TO AN
ENGINE THAT WE ARE VERY VERY
COMFORTABLE WITH WHICH IS
GIVING US LOW KNOCKS- AND LOW
CARBON. FOOTPRINT AND THE
ENGINE WORKS BY. VERY VERY WELL
IT'S COMPLETELY REBUILT
REPLACED ALL OF THE DEMANDS
THAT WE PUT ON A T. SHIRT
DIESEL VEHICLES WE ARE HOPING
TO ACHIEVE THOSE GOALS WITH
BATTERY ELECTRIC AND HOPEFULLY
HYDROGEN FUEL CELL. I HAVE TO
ADMIT THAT DR BROUWER'S
PRESENTATION GAVE ME A GREAT
DEAL OF HOPE BECAUSE WE HAVE
BEEN YOU KNOW TRYING TO DECIDE
WHAT WOULD BE THE TECH BEST
TECHNOLOGY FOR US LONG TERM WE
DO NOT BELIEVE THAT- D. THE
GREAT REQUIREMENTS AND THE DO
YOU STRESS THAT WILL FIT ON THE
GRID FOR ST BATTERY ELECTRIC
CLASS EIGHT VEHICLES WILL BE
SUSTAINABLE WE THINK THAT
THAT'S GOING TO BE A VERY VERY
DIFFICULT GOAL TO REACH. WE
HAVE EXPERIMENTED WITH HYDROGEN
AND THE ISSUES THAT WE THAT WE
HAVE. I HAVE EXPERIENCE WITH
HYDROGEN ARE NUMBER ONE.
NATURALLY THE ISSUE THE COST OF
THE VEHICLES THE VEHICLES ARE
THE KEY DEMONSTRATION REELS
THAT WE USE ARE EXTREMELY
EXPENSIVE. AND EXTREMELY- WE'VE
HAS A LOT OF ISSUES WITH- WITH
THE TECHNOLOGY ITSELF. I MANY
TIMES THE- THE CHILL CELLS ARE
UNDER POWERED THE TECHNOLOGY
TRUCK IS VERY VERY DIFFICULT
BECAUSE- IT'S A VERY VERY
TECHNICAL INSTRUMENT UNLIKE THE
AUTOMOBILES. WHICH TEND TO BE
MORE RELIABLE. FROM EIGHT AM AT
AS WE UNDERTAKE ANY OF THESE
DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGIES WE
ALWAYS LOOK TO. BE SEX SELF
SUSTAINABLE FROM A FUEL SOURCE
SO EVEN WITH NATURAL GAS WE
LOOKED AT EITHER A LEASING
STATIONS OURSELVES OR BUILDING
STATIONS. IN OUR FACILITIES TO
SERVICE OUR FLEET AS WE LOOK TO
HYDROGEN AS WE LOOKED INTO A TO
BATTERY ELECTRIC WE'RE ALSO
LOOKING FOR THOSE KIND OF
SOLUTIONS BECAUSE WE CANNOT BE
AT THE MERCY OF THE NETWORK NOT
BEING ABLE TO MEET OUR DEMANDS
BECAUSE WE WILL FAIL. TO
SERVICE OUR CUSTOMERS SO WHEN
WE LOOK AT THESE PROJECTS WE
LOOK AT IT FROM THE ASPECT OF
TOTALITY WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO.
SURVIVE FROM FROM CRADLE TO
GRAVE WITH THE WITH THE FUEL
AND THE AND THE TECHNOLOGY
ITSELF. WE HAVE MADE A GREAT
DEAL WE'VE MADE GREAT STRIDES
IN MOVING FORWARD ON THE-
BATTERY ELECTRIC FRONT. AGAIN
WE'RE VERY VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE- THE- THE GREAT ITSELF IN
THE POWER SOURCE. NOW WE'RE
WE'RE STARTING TO TAKE
DELIVERIES OF WE JUST TOOK
DELIVERY OF THE TOYOTA FUEL
CELL WE HAVE ANOTHER TOYOTA
FUEL CELL COMING WE'RE GONNA BE
TAKING DELIVERY OF SOME
ADDITIONAL FUEL CELLS FROM
TRANSPOWER. AND WE'VE SIGNED AN
AGREEMENT WITH NICHOLAW FOR
SIXTY FUEL CELL VEHICLES AND
FORTY BATTERY ELECTRIC
VEHICLES- AS I MENTIONED BEFORE
OUR PLAN IS TO. SLOWLY NOW
TRANSITION OUT OF NATURAL GAS
IN CALIFORNIA AND TRANSITION
INTO A FULL. ZERO EMISSIONS
FLEET- AND AS YOU'VE HEARD
THERE ARE THERE'S THE D. JUST
FROM THE LIGHT DUTY SIDE THE
REQUIREMENTS FROM THE- USERS
ARE REALLY ALL BOIL DOWN TO
INFRASTRUCTURE. SO I WOULD I
COMMEND THE WORK THAT CARBON
AND G. H. U. N. G. ARE DOING
AND HELPING DEVELOP AN EXTRA
TRIP BUT I THINK AND I BELIEVE
WE NEED A LOT MORE WORK DONE IN
THIS AREA. AND AGAIN I HAVE TO
STRESS THE COST THE COST OF
THESE VEHICLES AND THE COST OF
THE FUEL ITSELF. AFTER COME
DOWN DRAMATICALLY FOR IN ORDER
FOR US TO REMAIN COMPETITIVE IN
THE MARKETPLACE. BEING YOU KNOW
KIND OF A AN AN AN INITIAL USER
WE ARE TO TREMENDOUS
COMPETITIVE DISADVANTAGE- ACT
WHEN WE GO UP AGAINST THE
MARKET THAT IS EITHER. I'M
WILLING TO MAKE THE SWITCH OR
IS LYING BACK IN THE TRUCK AND
WAITING FOR SOMEONE ELSE TO.
YOU KNOW TAKE ALL THE ARROWS IN
THE BACK. AND WE JUST WE JUST
WANTED STATE COMMITTED AND WE
JUST WANT TO CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD TO GET TO. ZERO MEASURE
AND THE INFORMATION THAT I-
ASCERTAIN TODAY IS GOING TO BE
VERY VERY HELPFUL IN HELPING US
DEVELOP OUR FUTURE PLANS SO
AGAIN I THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY. AND I
FIND THE- THE PARTICIPANTS ON
THE PANEL FOR SHARING
INFORMATION WITH US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY- I REALLY APPRECIATED.
AND OUR LAST PRESENTER IS
REBECCA KAPLAN VICE MAYOR OF
THE CITY OF OAKLAND- MATTER
VICE MAYOR YOU HAVE THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR GOOD
AFTERNOON AND I INCREDIBLY
APPRECIATE THE INVITATION TO BE
A PART OF THIS IMPORTANT PANEL
AS WE TALK ABOUT THIS VITAL
STRATEGY THE USE OF HYDROGEN
FUEL CELL TECHNOLOGY TO MEET
OUR NEEDS FOR TRANSPORTATION
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
SUSTAINABILITY AND TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC HEALTH. I AM THE
VICE MAYOR OF OAKLAND
COUNCILMEMBER AT LARGE SAY
REPRESENT THE ENTIRE CITY AND
PRIOR TO THAT I SERVED ON THE
BOARD OF AC TRANSIT OUR LOCAL
BUS OPERATOR WHICH TWO DECADES
AGO BECAME ONE OF THE FIRST TO
ADOPT THE USE OF HYDROGEN FUEL
CELL TECHNOLOGY. AND SO I'VE
BEEN INVOLVED IN THIS EFFORT
FOR SOME TIME AND I THINK IT IS
INCREDIBLY PROMISING AND VITAL
THAT WE TAKE THE STEPS NOW TO
EXPAND THE USE OF HYDROGEN FUEL
CELL TECHNOLOGY. WE HAVE BEEN
USING IT THROUGH AC TRANSIT FOR
BUSES OVER TWO DECADES AND THE
HYDROGEN FUEL CELL BUSES ARE
HAVING EXCELLENT PERFORMANCE
EXCELLENT RELIABILITY AND ZERO
EMISSIONS AND SO IN RECENT
MONTHS I'VE BEEN WORKING
TOGETHER WITH MANY DIFFERENT
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION THE BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT THE
PORT OF OAKLAND. EAST BAY MUD
AND WITH THE SUPPORT OF CARB
AND THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION WE ARE LAUNCHING
ZERO EMISSION HYDROGEN FUEL
CELL TRUCK PROGRAM AT THE PORT
OF OAKLAND. WHICH IS SOME
OTHERS ON THIS PANEL ARE ALSO
FAMILIAR WITH BUT THE ABILITY
TO LAUNCH HYDROGEN FUEL CELL
TRUCKS IS REALLY IMPORTANT FOR
MULTIPLE REASONS INCLUDING TO
REDUCE THE POLLUTION IMPACTS ON
OUR COMMUNITY AND I'M GOING TO
SHARE A SLIDE TO HIGHLIGHT THIS
POINT. THE D. AIR POLLUTION
THIS IS A MAP THAT WAS PRODUCED
BY THE BAY AREA AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT SHOWING THE
AIR POLLUTION CANCER RISK TWO
THOUSAND FIVE AND THEN TEN
YEARS LATER AND THIS PURPLE
LINE SHOWING WITH THE HIGHEST
DE. OF POLLUTION IS IF YOU'RE
FAMILIAR WITH THE EAST BAY
REGION THIS TRACKS THE EIGHT
EIGHTY HIGHWAY THROUGH EAST
OAKLAND STARTING IN SAN LEANDRO
UP THROUGH EAST OAKLAND. AND
THEN HERE INTO WEST OAKLAND
AROUND THE PORT AND SO THIS IS
WHERE WE SEE THE CONTINUED
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE OF AIR
POLLUTION. AND ASTHMA CANCER
AND ALL OF THE NEGATIVE HEALTH
IMPACTS BECOME WITHOUT
POLLUTION. AND THIS IS
PREDOMINATELY OVER AN AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY AND
PREDOMINANTLY OVER LOWER INCOME
COMMUNITY THAT HAS BEEN
SUBJECTED FOR DECADES. TO THIS
DISPROPORTIONATE AIR POLLUTION
AND THAT IS COMING LARGELY FROM
DIESEL PARTICULATE EMISSIONS
FROM TRUCKS. AND SO THIS IS A
TRUCK CORRIDOR IT SERVES NOT
ONLY THE PORT OF OAKLAND BUT
ALSO TO VARIOUS WAREHOUSES AND
OTHER FACILITIES. AND THE
DIESEL EMISSIONS FROM THE
TRUCKS ARE THE MAJOR SOURCE OF
HELP FORMING POLLUTION IN THIS
AREA. AND SO FIGURING OUT HOW
TO DO ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS. IS
REALLY ESSENTIAL BOTH TO THE
GLOBAL CLIMATE AND TO THE HUMAN
HEALTH OF THE COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE MOST DESPERATELY IMPACTED.
AND SO WE HAVE PURSUED ALL OF
THE DIFFERENT AVAILABLE
TECHNOLOGIES WE DO HAVE SOME
BATTERY ELECTRIC TRUCKS AS WELL
AS BATTERY AND HYBRID ELECTRIC
CRANES GOING IN AT THE PORT OF
OAKLAND- AND SOME THAT HAVE
ALREADY BEEN INSTALLED. BUT
WHEN IT COMES TO A LONG HOLD
VEHICLES THE BATTERIES ARE NOT
SUFFICIENT AND SO IT IS VITAL
THAT WE ALSO INCLUDE AND EXPAND
THE USE. OF HYDROGEN FUEL CELL
WHICH HAS THE DURABILITY AS
WELL AS THE ABILITY TO SERVE
THOSE LONGER DISTANCES. IN
BETWEEN FUELING AND SO WE ARE
SUPER GRATEFUL FOR THE NEW
STATE FUNDING THAT WAS
ANNOUNCED YESTERDAY IT WILL
ALLOW US TO LAUNCH A MAJOR
FUELING STATION- IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE PORT OF OAKLAND AND A
BATCH OF TRUCKS. AND OF COURSE
HAVING THIS FEELING STATION
WILL ALLOW US TO ATTRACT OTHER
TRUCKS EVEN BEYOND THE ONES
THAT ARE PART OF THE GRANT
FUNDED PROJECT. I WOULD ALSO
NOTE THAT. THE ABILITY TO DRIVE
THEM ON THE STREETS WITH THAT
NEEDED WICKS ARE ALSO PART OF
THE PATH THAT WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT. END IN ADDITION WE
ARE PURSUING LONGER TERM THE
ABILITY TO HAVE LOCALLY
PRODUCED SUSTAINABLY PRODUCED
HYDROGEN IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
EAST BAY MUD WHICH IS OUR WASTE
WATER HANDLING- UTILITY. AND SO
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT IS
CERTAINLY TO BE LOOKING TO FIND
ARE THE SUSTAINABLE PRODUCTION
OF HYDROGEN THAT THAT IS ONE OF
THE ADDITIONAL OPTIONS THE WE
ARE PURSUING AND THAT SHOULD BE
PART OF OUR FUTURE. I WOULD
ALSO NOTE STATE LAST SUMMER
WHEN WE HAD SOME OF THE WORST
AIR QUALITY DAYS OF ALL TIME
WHEN IT WAS INCREDIBLY HOT AND
WE WERE COVERED WITH SMOKE FROM
WILDFIRES. IT LARGE FACILITIES
LIKE THE PORT OF OAKLAND WERE
DIRECTED TO CUT BACK ON THEIR
ELECTRICITY USE WERE DIRECTED
TO STOP ELECTRICITY USE AND SO
A PATH TOWARDS ZERO EMISSIONS
THAT RELIES PURELY ON
ELECTRICITY WAS THEN SHUT DOWN
ON THE WORST POLLUTION DAYS.
AND THEY WERE TOLD TO THEN TURN
ON DIESEL. BECAUSE OF THE
INABILITY TO USE THE ELECTRICAL
GRID HYDROGEN FUEL CELL CAN
SOLVE THAT PROBLEM WE CAN HAVE
SOMETHING THAT IS ZERO
EMISSIONS THAT DOES NOT
POLLUTE. AND WHICH ALSO IS
AVAILABLE TO BE USED EVEN ON
DAYS WHEN THE ELECTRIC GRID MAY
BE STRAINED AND IN FACT THE USE
OF HYDROGEN CAN REDUCE THAT
STRAIN ON THE ELECTRICITY GRID.
SO THIS IS VITALLY IMPORTANT
FOR OUR REGION AS WELL AS FOR
OUR GLOBAL SUSTAINABILITY. ONE
OF THE OTHER THINGS I THINK
IT'S USEFUL TOTHINK ABOUT IN
THIS CONTEXT IS THAT FREIGHT IS
OFTEN LEFT OUT OF THE CONTEXT
OF REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
PLANNING AND OTHER EFFORTS AND
YET FREE IS. A FAR MORE
SIGNIFICANT SOURCE OF POLLUTION
IN TRANSPORTATION SO FOR
EXAMPLE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
HAS EIGHT CASH FOR CLUNKERS
PROGRAM FOR CARS WHERE YOU CAN
TURN IN A POLLUTING OLD CAR FOR
MONEY AND IT GETS TAKEN OFF
ROAD. WE ALSO NEED A CASH FOR
CLUNKERS PROGRAM FOR TRUCKS WE
HAVE BAD POLITICAL TRUST THAT
COULD BE BOUGHT AND TAKEN OFF
THE ROAD. AND WHEN WE LOOK AT
THE DIFFERENT STRATEGIES TO
REDUCE EMISSIONS AND REDUCE
POLLUTION WE NEED TO
INCORPORATE FREE AS WELL AS
PASSENGER VEHICLES. AS WE LOOK
AT THESE STRATEGIES. ONE OF THE
ADVANTAGES OF LOOKING AT
CENTRALLY LOCATED FUELED LEADS
IS THAT WE CAN SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASE THE USE OF HYDROGEN
EVEN AS WE CONTINUE TO BUILD
OUT MORE STATIONS. SO WHEN YOU
HAVE A FACILITY LIKE A PORT. IT
IS SERVED BY MANY VEHICLES
HAVING HYDROGEN FUELING IN
THOSE LOCATIONS CAN GREATLY
ENABLED THE UPTAKE BY MANY MORE
USERS WHO USE THOSE FACILITIES.
IN ADDITION THE NEW FUELING
STATION AT THE PORT OF OAKLAND
WILL ALLOW HYDROGEN TRUCKS TO
SERVE THE ENTIRE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA TO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CORRIDOR WITH
FUELING AVAILABLE ON BOTH ENDS.
AS WELL AS SERVING AREAS BEYOND
HERE URTHER NORTH AND FURTHER
EAST. SO IT IS AS SOME OF THE
OTHER SPEAKERS HAVE POINTED OUT
VITALLY IMPORTANT TO HAVE THOSE
FUELING STATIONS AND TO HAVE
THEM IN THE LOCATIONS WHERE
THEY ARE NEEDED. TO MAXIMIZE
THESE USES IN WAYS THAT REDUCE
THE POLLUTION REDUCE THE
IMPACTS ON OUR COMMUNITY AND
EVEN ALLOW US TO PRODUCE OUR
OWN FUEL FROM WASTE SO WE
ENCOURAGE THAT THAT BE PART OF
WHAT IS EXPANDED. IN THE
RESEARCH AND FUNDING GOING
FORWARD AS WELL AS PROGRAMS
LIKE THOSE BEING LAUNCHED NOW
FOR THE TRUCKS AND THE FUELING
STATIONS. AS WE SEE MORE AND
MORE ADOPTION OF THESE HEAVY
DUTY USES THOSE FILLING
STATIONS ALSO CAN ENABLE THE
LIGHT DUTY USERS AS WELL SO WE
CAN SERVE BOTH AS NEEDED IN
SOME FACILITIES. BUT I THINK
IT'S VITAL THAT WE NOT LEAVE
OUT THE HEAVY DUTY USES AS
THOSE CAN HAVE A VERY DRAMATIC
IMPACT. ON REDUCING THE
POLLUTION IMPACTS ON OUR
COMMUNITIES AND HAVING SEEN
OVER TWENTY YEARS THE SUCCESS
OF THE AC TRANSIT HYDROGEN FUEL
CELL BUSES WHICH ARE A SIMILAR
SIZE TO WHAT WE SEE FOR TRUCKS.
WE KNOW THAT THIS TECHNOLOGY
CAN WORK WELL FOR THE HEAVY
DUTY USES AND SO I WANTED TO
SHARE THAT GOOD NEWS AND THAT.
THOUGHT AS WE MOVE FORWARD AND
I'M SO GRATEFUL FOR THE EXIT
SINCE OF THIS COME. AND HAPPY
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU AS
WE WORK TO IMPROVE OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND THE HEALTH OF
OUR COMMUNITIES. AND BUILD A
MORE SUSTAINABLE FUTURE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE TIME AND
ATTENTION. THANK YOU MADAM VICE
MAYOR- SO STAND BY WE'RE GOING
pGOING TO ASK SOME OF THE
SENATORS WHO ARE HOPEFULLY ARE
STILL WITH US SENATOR BEN ALLEN
CENTER AND A CABRILLO. SENATOR
BEN WESO CENTER BRIAN JONES
CENTER JOSH NEWMAN AND CENTER
NANCY SKINNER SO SENATORS- THE
FLOORS OPEN IF YOU'D LIKE TO-
JUMP IN WITH QUESTIONS YOU'RE
MORE THAN WELCOME. ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM OUR
SENATORS. ANYONE ON THE LINE.
IF NOT I'M GOING TO START OFF
WITH A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS
PHILLIPS- ARE VERY FIRST
PANELISTS IF YOU RECALL THE
DOCTOR- JACK BAUER HERE'S MY
QUESTION TO YOU THAT- TO GET
THIS COSTS DOWN OF HYDROGEN-
AND TO REDUCE THE COST OF THE
CARS NOW IN PRODUCTION. WHAT
WOULD YOUR RECOMMENDATION. WELL
FIRST OF ALL WE SHOULD
UNDERSTAND THAT THE- PLACE THAT
THESE TECHNOLOGIES ARE ON THE
COST CURVE IS VERY STEEP. IT
HAS NOT ENGENDERED AS MUCH
INVESTMENT AS THINGS LIKE SOLAR
BATTERIES AND THOSE TECHNOLOGY
IS WILL HAVE A SIMILAR COST
REDUCTION KERR BY I PREDICT TWO
COMPARED TO BATTERIES AND SOLAR
AND SO INVESTMENT IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO ENABLE THE
EXPERIENCE. OF THE DRIVERS OKAY
ESPECIALLY WITH REGARD TO
FUELING I THINK IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT I THINK THIS IS THE
MOST CRITICAL ITEM THAT WE HAD
THAT WE FACE TODAY. TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE A GOOD AN
ADEQUATE HYDROGEN SUPPLY
ADEQUATE HYDROGEN FUELING
STATIONS AN AT THE CEILING
STATIONS CONTINUE TO BE AN
OPERATION AND OPERATE WELL-
THERE ALSO COULD BE- THE
CONSIDERATION OF. YOU KNOW HOW
L. CFS CREDITS ARE APPLIED IN
THIS PARTICULAR CASE AND I
THINK THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR. FOR THIS FUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE TO BE INCLUDED
IN THE LCS US CREDIT SYSTEM I
THINK IT SHOULD CONTINUE. AND
THE WINNER WHEN A COUPLE OF
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS- WHY IS A
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA GAS COMPANY
SO EXCITED ABOUT HYDROGEN IN
THEIR LINES IN THERE WITH
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE HYDROGEN
INDUSTRY. BUT LET ME SUGGEST I
THINK IT OFFERS THEM ONE OF THE
MOST PROMISING VECTORS FOR
RETAINING A REASONABLE BUSINESS
IN A ZERO EMISSIONS WORLD- FROM
MY PERSPECTIVE THE WELL IT'S
OBVIOUS IT'S A LAW THAT WE WILL
NOT BE USING FOSSIL FUELS IN
TWENTY FORTY FIVE. AND IF
THAT'S THE CASE THERE NEEDS TO
BE AN ALTERNATIVE THAT CAN THAT
CAN BE USED THAT CAN USE THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND I SUGGEST
ALSO THAT THAT INFRASTRUCTURE
IS VERY VALUABLE. THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE SUPER VALUABLE
TO OUR ZERO EMISSIONS GOALS BUT
WE MUST TRANSFORM IT. CAN'T
JUST STATE- TRANSMITTING
FOSSEL- GAS NOT MAYBE A SMALL
AMOUNT OF FOSSIL GAS COULD BE
USED IN CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES
WITH CARBON CAPTURE AND STORAGE
BUT I THINK THAT BY FAR AND
AWAY. THE MOST IMPORTANT
TRANSFORMATION WILL BE TO
RENEWABLE HYDROGEN. SO YOU
THINK THAT- INSERTING AT LEAST
5% HYDROGEN INTO THE NATURAL
GAS PIPELINE WOULD BE SAFE IT
WOULD BE PRUDENT. AND IT WOULD
BE THE WAY OF THE FUTURE AND
ALSO- IT WOULD BE SAFE AT WITH
THAT NATURAL GAS FOR THE
PIPELINE TO THE USAGE IS THAT
CORRECT. BUT WE SUGGEST THAT
THERE ARE A VERY LARGE NUMBER
OF RESEARCH DEVELOPMENT AND
DEMONSTRATION- PROJECTS THAT
SHOULD BE ACCOMPLISHED BEFORE
WE WOULD. INJECT IT EVERYWHERE-
BUT MOST OF THE STUDIES BOTH
HERE IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
IN OTHER JURISDICTIONS HAVE
FOUND THAT MIXTURES UP TO A
CERTAIN PERCENTAGE SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN TEN AND FIVE AND 20% OR
SO. ARE LIKELY TO BE VERY SAFE
UNDER MOST CIRCUMSTANCES NOW
AGAIN. THERE NEEDS TO BE
INVESTMENT TO MAKE SURE IT'S
SAFE WHEREVER WE'RE GOING TO DO
IT BUGS VERY IMPORTANTLY. V.
TRANSFORMATION OR THE
INTRODUCTION OF 5% IT IS NOT SO
IMPORTANT WITH REGARD TO
DECARBONISING GAS BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T GIVE US A BIG
DECARBONISATION IMPACT ON THE
GAS SYSTEM. IT'S MOST IMPORTANT
FOR ENGENDERING. EIGHT
RENEWABLE ELECTRICITY OFFTAKE
IT'S FOR ENABLING THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO CONTINUE TO
MASSIVELY INVEST IN SOLAR AND
WIND ELECTRICITY BECAUSE THAT
WILL BE THE BOSS TAKE WHEN WE
DON'T WANT IT RIGHT NOW LIKE
WHAT'S CURRENTLY HAPPENING
WE'RE CURTAILING MASSIVE
AMOUNTS OF RENEWABLE
ELECTRICITY TODAY SO WHENEVER
THERE IS A CHEAPOR OTHERWISE
CURTAILED ELECTRICITY WE CAN
USE THE HYDROGEN VECTOR AND
INJECTION UP 25% IN THE GAS
SYSTEM WILL. ENABLE A LOT OF
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT IN SOLAR
AND WIND AND LET ME LET ME JUST
MENTION THOUGH 5% IT INJECTION
IN THE GAS SYSTEM WILL BE
INVESTIGATED AND INVESTED IN
AND THEN YOU CAN ALSO DETERMINE
HOW YOU CAN TRANSFORM FROM THE
INITIAL PARTIAL DETERMINATION
DECARBONISATION OF THE GAS
SYSTEM DOES START TO FIGURE
OUT- THIS IS WHERE WE REALLY
HAVE A LEAKAGE PROBLEM- THIS IS
WHERE IT REALLY WHERE WE
HAVEN'T- MATERIAL DEGRADATION
PROBLEMS AND YOU'LL START TO
SAY OKAY I'M GONNA TAKE THIS
PIPE OUT AND I'M GONNA PUT IN A
DIFFERENT LIGHT. I'M TO TAKE
THIS VALVE OUT AMID PUT IN A
DIFFERENT DOLLARS WE'RE GOING
TO COPE THIS OVER HE AND THEN
IT CAN A 100% TYPE REGION IN
THE FUTURE. WHAT WE HAVE TO
START INVESTING IN AT AND THE
5% IS IMPORTANT FOR THIS
BEGINNING OF THE INVESTMENT.
INVESTING IN AND- HI JR NOVICE
IS THE WAY TO GO- SO OF GOT A
DISH QUESTIONS- LET'S SEE-
ANDREW MARTINEZ- I WOULD LIKE
TO ASK YOU- HE HAD MENTIONED
ABOUT THE NUMBER OF STATIONS
THAT ARE. THAT WOULD BE NEEDED
IN THE FUTURE- SO WHAT HAPPENS
AFTER THAT THE TWO HUNDRED
STATIONS ARE PUT IN- ARE WE
GOING TO CONTINUE. LOOKING IN
THAT DIRECTION WITH THE
EXPANSION OF THE AUTOMOBILES
AND- THE POPULARITY OF THE FUEL
CELL CARS WHAT HAPPENS WITH
THAT NUMBER. WE LOOK INTO AN
INCREASE. YES SO- OUR DRAFT
SELF SUFFICIENCY REPORT LOOKS
AT THIS QUESTION- IN TERMS OF
HYPOTHETICAL POTENTIAL FUTURE
SCENARIOS. AND WE HAVE LOOKED
AT POTENTIAL SCENARIOS THAT ARE
BILLED. I JUST A FEW MORE
STATIONS OUT TO ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED STATIONS OR SCENARIOS
THAT BUILD. UP TO- ABOUT ONE
THOUSAND STATIONS AND IN TWENTY
THIRTY AND MORE BEYOND- OUR
DRAFT REPORT. DISCUSSES THE
POSSIBILITIES OF THESE
DIFFERENT SCENARIOS- BUT IN
TERMS OF ACTUAL THE ACTUAL-
DECISION MAKING THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT I PERSONALLY
CANNOT SPEAK TO- AND I THINK
THAT WE CAN ALL FIND THAT WE'RE
ALL LOOKING FOR CLEAN
ENVIRONMENT AND OBVIOUSLY- I
MENTIONED THE TREASURE CHEST OF
ENERGY. AND I'M SO GLAD THAT
YOU ARE PARTICIPATING TODAY
BECAUSE YOU CAN SEE BY THE
PANELISTS THAN WHAT YOU'VE
HEARD THAT INCLUDING HYDROGEN
IN THAT TREASURE CHEST OF
ENERGY IS SO IMPORTANT. SO I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU IN THE FUTURE ON THIS SO
LET'S GO OVER SOME OF THE
OTHERS- AMERICAN RED CROSS.
LESLIE MORE WE WERE CHAU OF
PROUD OF WHAT YOU DO THE
AMERICAN RED CROSS YOU HAD
MENTIONED HOW. SOME OF YOUR
VEHICLES ARE. ARE RUNNING ON
HYDROGEN LIKE TO THANK YOU
ABOUT THAT SO I'D LIKE TO JUST
HAVE YOU COME BACK IN. AND CAN
YOU GIVE US AN EXAMPLE HOW. IT
WAS A SURPRISE TO YOU THE
ECONOMY OR THE DISTANCE WHAT
SURPRISED YOU ABOUT. THE FUEL
CELL HYDROGEN AUTOMOBILE. OF
THE AUTOMOBILE ITSELF- IT IS
ACTUALLY THERE WERE NO
SURPRISES IT RUNS EXACTLY THE
WAY GAS VEHICLE RUNS TO ME- I
DRIVE THEM EVERY WEK I THINK
THE SURPRISE WAS REALLY JUST IN
THE FUELING AND US SOME OF THAT
THE CHALLENGES IN THE ACTUAL
KILLING STATIONS IT JUST IT
JUST TAKES LIKE ONE LITTLE
THING A MECHANICAL ISSUE OR
SOMETHING TO KIND OF- TO SHUT
THE WHOLE STATION DOWN SO THAT
WAS A LITTLE BIT OF A SURPRISE
BUT THE VEHICLE ITSELF. THEY'RE
THE ONES WE HAVE THE CHOI ARISE
THERE TWENTY SEVENTEENS THEY
WERE GIFTED TO US WITH THIRTY
THOUSAND MILES ON THEM- OR LAST
AND I HAVE NO ISSUE WITH THEM
THEY THEY HANDLE REALLY WELL
AND- I'M REALLY IMPRESSED WITH
THE TECHNOLOGY ACTUALLY VERY
GOOD THANK YOU AND- HYUNDAI
MOTOR COMPANY- THIS IS DUMB AND
YOU HAD- YOU DIDN'T HOLD BACK
OBVIOUSLY YOU FEEL THAT WE NEED
THE INFRASTRUCTURE MORE
STATIONS OBVIOUSLY WITH THE
POPULARITY IN THE- THE
PRODUCTION THAT YOU ANTICIPATE-
YOU'RE ASKING THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA REALLY TAKE A STRONG
LOOK AT. THE EXPANSION OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE. COULD YOU
COMMENT A LITTLE BIT MORE ON
THAT. ABSOLUTELY AGAIN I THINK
I THINK WE'RE ALL IN ALIGNMENT
AND WE ALL KIND OF WANT THE
SAME THING TO ADVANCE TO WORK
THIS ZERO MISSION WORLD AND- I
THINK IT WAS FOR TWO IS THAT
COMMENTS FROM A SMALL RIGHT
BEFORE I PRESENTED. JUST WANT
TO REITERATE SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES SO IT'S
INFRASTRUCTURE STATION
RELIABILITY. WE NOW IT'S THE
WHOLE CHICKEN OR THE EGG
DILEMMA BUT- WE SEE HUGE
POTENTIAL WETHINK THERE'S
MULTIPLE SOLUTIONS TO REACH OUR
GOALS. WERE AS A COMPANY ARE
COMMITTED TO MULTIPLE
TECHNOLOGIES AND FUEL CELLS ONE
OF OUR KEY PILLAR SO WE JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE. THE CUSTOMERS
LOVE THEIR CARS LOVE THE
EXPERIENCE AS WELL SO THEY CAN
BUY ANOTHER ONE. AND OF COURSE
TELL THEIR FRIENDS AND THE KIND
OF EXPONENTIALLY GROWS INTO A
LOT OF. FUEL CELLS ON THE ROAD.
THANK YOU. OF BIGELOW ROCHA IF
C. M. PRESIDENT FOUNDER OF.
TOTAL TRANSPORTATION SERVICES
YOU HAD MENTIONED. ABOUT YOUR
RESEARCH IN IN- GERMANY. AND
THE USAGE OUT THERE VERSUS
HERE. DO YOU SEE. THAT ALL
THESE OTHER COUNTRIES ARE FAR
AHEAD OF US. AND WE'RE TO CATCH
UP MODE. WHAT WHAT'S YOUR- YOUR
VALUATION ON THAT. I THINK THAT
THEY'VE BEEN AT IT LONGER- THEN
WE HAVE BEEN. I YOU KNOW TO SAY
THAT WE'RE GONNA CATCH UP MODE
I THINK WOULD BE KIND OF- AT
THIS SERVICE BECAUSE I THINK
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN KIND OF A
LEADER YEAH KIND OF LEADING A
LEADING EDGE. I JUST THINK THAT
THE TECHNOLOGY IS CHAU
COMPLICATED BUT IT'S GOING TO
TAKE SOME SOME ADDITIONAL TIME
TO GET US WHERE WE AS AN
INDUSTRY ARE CONFIDENT THAT.
WE'VE GOT A RELIABLE PRODUCTS.
I THINK YOU WILL AGREE THAT
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY HERE FOR
A WORKFORCE TO DEVELOP TO BE
ABLE TO BE THE TECHNICIANS OF
THE FUTURE TO WORK ON THE
CHARGING FUEL CELL- AUTOMOBILES
AND- AND- SUVS AND OF COURSE AS
YOU MENTIONED THE HEAVY HEAVIER
TRUCKS- SO. TALKING ABOUT
HEAVIER TRUCKS- REBECCA KAPLAN
MADAM VICE MAYOR FROM OAKLAND-
I AM SO EXCITED ABOUT HEARING
WHAT YOU'RE DOING AND IN
OAKLAND AND HOW YOU'VE TAKEN ON
THE SERVICES OF. OF BRINGING
HYDROGEN INTO OAKLAND I THINK
I'M GOING TO ASK THE TO COME BY
AND VISIT. AND SEE SOME OF THE-
THE WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING
THERE SO YOU CAN YOU COMMENT ON
A LITTLE BIT ON THE FUTURE OF
OAKLAND AND THE PARTNERSHIP YOU
HAVE WITH THE ENERGY. WHEN IT
COMES TO FUELCELL ENERGY. YES
ABSOLUTELY NO WE ARE SO EXCITED
ABOUT THE NEW PROGRAM THAT IS
COMING WITH THE STATE GRANT SO
THANK YOU TO ALL OF THE STATE
LEADERS- INVOLVED IN THAT
EFFORT. TO HAVE THE HYDROGEN
FUELING STATION AND THIS IS
SOMETHING I HAVE BEEN FIGHTING
FOR OF FOR MULTIPLE YEARS WE
RECOGNIZE THE MAJOR POLLUTION
IMPACTS. AND I DO WANT TO SAY
THAT I'M VERY HOPEFUL FOR THE
TECHNOLOGY THERE IS ALSO AN
ECONOMIES OF SCALE ISSUE SO
WHEN PEOPLE TALK ABOUT SOME OF
THE BOMBS WITH SOME OF THE
INITIAL ROLLOUT OF SOME OF THE
STATIONS. AND THINGS LIKE THAT
YOU KNOW ONCE THEY'RE START
BEING MORE OF THEM THE PRICE
WILL COME DOWN THE RELIABILITY
IMPROVES AND SO I THINK WE'RE
REALLY AT THIS POINT IN THE
CURVE. WHERE A SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT CAN MAKE A
TRANSFORMATION NOT ONLY IN THE
GRANT HELPING TO FUND
ADDITIONAL VEHICLES BUT REALLY
GET US PAST THAT ECONOMIES OF
SCALE ISSUE WHERE THERE WILL BE
ENOUGH HYDROGEN FUELING
STATIONS. AND ANOTHER-
DEVELOPMENT OF HYDROGEN FUELING
VEHICLES THAT YOU'LL BE ABLE TO
HAVE MORE PEOPLE TRAINED IN HOW
TO MAINTAIN THEM. THE YOU'LL BE
ABLE TO HAVE ENOUGH FUELING
STATIONS THE PEOPLE CAN
RELIABLY GO TO THEM AND WITH
THE TRUCKS THEY WILL BE ABLE TO
SHOW THE RELIABILITY. BECAUSE
COMPANIES WHEN THEY'RE LOOKING
AT BUYING A TRUCK YOU KNOW THEY
NEED A FAIRLY HIGH LEVEL OF
CERTAINTY OF THE RELIABILITY OF
THAT. AND SO ONCE WE ARE ABLE
TO SHOW THIS LAUNCH WITH THE
MANY VEHICLES IT REALLY CAN BE
THE KIND OF TURNING POINT. THE
WILL INCENTIVIZE MANY MORE
PEOPLE TO DO IT AND ONCE MORE
PEOPLE ARE BUYING THEM THE
PRICE PER VEHICLE WILL GO DOWN
BECAUSE OF THE ECONOMIES OF
SCALE. IN THE PRODUCTION AND
YOU KNOW THE AND THANK YOU FOR
ASKING THE FOLLOWING QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE TRUCKS UGH NO
DISRESPECT FOR WORKING ON THE
CARS THAT'S IMPORTANT TOO. BUT
IN TERMS OF THE HUMAN HEALTH
IMPACT REMEDYING THE HISTORIES
OF ENVIRONMENTAL INJUSTICE
MAKING SURE THAT WE YOUR ALSO
DEALING WITH THE TRUCK. IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT IN TERMS
OF THE ASTHMA AND THE OTHER
NEGATIVE HEALTH HEALTH IMPACTS.
OF TRUCK POLLUTION SO I'M
REALLY GRATEFUL- THAT THAT IS
PART OF THE VENTURE AS WELL.
THANK YOU AND YOU DID MENTION
BUSES AND BY THE WAY I DID HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY RIDE. ON A BUS
HERE CHECKER MEADOW AND SMOOTH
QUIET AND N. VERY FISSION. I
LOVE THE EXPERIENCE LET'S GO
AHEAD AND MOVE ON- TO PUBLIC
COMMENTS AND THE PANELISTS. IF
THERE'S A QUESTION FROM THE
PUBLIC- THAT SEEMS TO BE IN
YOUR CATEGORY WOULD YOU JUMP
IN. AND TAKE CARE OF THAT FOR
US. AS A REMINDER- LATER JOHN
TO PLACE A OF A PUBLIC COMMENT
PLEASE DIAL. THIS TOLL FREE
NUMBER EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE THREE
WHEN PROMPTED PLEASE USE THE
CODE THE ACCESS CODE WHICH IS
SEVEN OH FIVE. SIX NINE OH
NINE. LET'S BE WITH ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE GALLERY
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE. AND
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND- WE
WILL GO AHEAD AND OPEN THE
FLOOR UP FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK YOU SENATOR TERESA KIRK
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA AND
PLEASE SPEAK. LOUD AND CLEAR
CLOSE TO THE MICROPHONE TO WE
CAN HEAR YOU. I'M LORD OUR GOD.
THERESA COOK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN COALITION I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THIS
COMMITTEE HEARING TODAY- AND
FOR THE TESTIMONY OF THOSE
PRESENT WHAT I HEARD TODAY IS A
NEED FOR A TRULY INTEGRATED
TRANSPORTATION AND ENERGY
SYSTEM. I THINK THAT'S LACKING
IN POLICY AND WE HAVE A LITTLE
BIT OF WORK TAT WE NEED TO DO
VERY VERY QUICKLY TO COMPENSATE
FOR THAT AND I THINK THIS IS A
BIG STEP FORWARD TO ACHIEVE
THOSE ENDS. YOU ASKED A MOMENT
AGO ABOUT THE POLICIES THAT WE
MIGHT PURSUE IN ORDER TO LOWER
THE COST OF HYDROGEN FUEL AND
SO I JUST WANT TO OFFER AND IT
WAS MENTIONED BY ONE OF THOSE
TESTIMONY. THAT JUST BE
CURTAILED ENERGY BACK
CALIFORNIA- YOU KNOW GROUNDS
ARE GIVES AWAY OR PAYS YOU KNOW
ARIZONA TO TAKE FROM US IF WE
WERE TO TURN THAT INTO POWER TO
CREATE HYDROGEN WE WOULD HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO FUEL TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND VEHICLES JUST LAST
YEAR SO AN INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITY. FOR THIS OTHERWISE
CURTAILED POWER THAT WE WOULD
LIKE TO EXPLORE PERHAPS
WHOLESALE RATING OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT SO THAT WE CAN YOU
KNOW USE THAT TO MAKE A CHEAP
AND RENEWABLE HYDROGEN FUEL.
THE OTHER ITEM I'D THAT IS
WORTH CONSIDERING IN THIS IS
MORE RELATED TO THE AIR BE
SCOPING PLAN AND THAT IS-
UTILIZING THE CAPACITY CREDIT
UNDER THE LOW CARBON FUEL
STANDARD FOR HEAVY DUTY FUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE ASWELL IN
TWENTY NINETEEN THAT CHANGE WAS
ONLY MADE FOR LIGHT DUTY. AND
JUST ONE OBSERVATION THAT I
WANT TO MAKE THAT I THINK IS
TENDS TO GET LOST IN THESE
CONVERSATIONS IS SORT OF A
SCHISM BETWEEN LIGHT DUTY AND
HEAVY DUTY THAT DOESN'T
ACTUALLY EXIST- IN TERMS OF THE
WAY THAT THE MARKET ACTUALLY
OPERATES. TODAY BY MEDIUM DUTY
VEHICLES UP TO CLASSICS WILL BE
UTILIZING LIGHT DUTY
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SO WHEN WE
TALK AS A BODY ABOUT NEEDING
TO. DECARBONIZE TRANSPORTATION
AND ARE MOST AFFECTED
COMMUNITIES AND LAST MILE
DELIVERY TRUCKS BEING SORT OF A
PERPETRATOR OF THOSE EMISSIONS
WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT HYDROGEN
FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE NOT ONLY
SUPPORTING JUST MY VEHICLE WITH
MY FAMILY. BUT YOU KNOW
DELIVERIES AND THINGS ALONG.
THOSE LINES- SO BEYOND NOT
EVERY SAVE YOU SO MUCH AND LOOK
FOR TO WORK WITH. THIS
COMMITTEE AND APPRECIATE ALL
THE SUPPORT AND WORK THAT WENT
INTO THAT SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. JOHN.
HELLO YEAH YOU KNOW. FIVE FIVE
DO MY BEST. THE LITTLE. OKAY
THANK YOU AND WELCOME. HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW. OKAY
PROBLEM. HI SO LET'S TRY IT
AGAIN GO AHEAD THANK YOU MISTER%
CHAIR AND MEMBERS FOR HOLDING
THE SENATE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
HYDROGEN TODAY IM SERVICE IM IN
NELSON FROM THE CALIFORNIA
HYDROGEN BUSINESS COUNCIL I.
FULL HEARTEDLY AGREE WITH
EVERYTHING THAT I TREE SAID
JUST AT SAID FROM THE
CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN COALITION-
I'LL TOUCH ON JUST ANOTHER
IMPORTANT ASPECT OF THIS
CONVERSATION AGAIN ALL THE
PANELISTS TODAY WERE AMAZING WE
WORK DR JACK BAUER ALL THE TIME
HE'S ONE OF OUR MEMBERS OF OUR
ORGANIZATION AND E. I AND
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE NOW IS ALSO
OUR MEMBERS SO WE'RE VERY PROUD
OF. THOSE MEMBERS IN THE
PANELISTS THAT SPOKE TODAY JUST
THE PROGRESS THAT'S BEING DONE
IS GREAT- BUT I DO WANT TO
TOUCH ON ONE IMPORTANT ASPECT
THAT I THINK IS REALLY
IMPORTANT TO REIN IN IS THAT
46% OF CALIFORNIANS LIVE IN
MULTI UNIT HOUSING AND DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO CHARGING A LOT
OF THE TIMES AND WE'RE GONNA BE
REACHING THIS. MILESTONE THAT
GOVERNOR NEWSOM HAD PUT FORWARD
TO DO 1100% ZERO MISSION SALES
BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE YOU
REALLY DO NEED TO HAVE A LOT OF
OPTIONS THAT WORK FOR EVERYONE
AND SO THE HYDROGEN FUEL CELL
ELECTRIC VEHICLES REALLY DON'T
REQUIRE PARKING FOR A LONG
PERIOD OF TIME TO REFILL
THEMSELVES IT'S JUST. AT A GAS
STATION THAT YOU WOULD GO TO
AND FILL IT UP YOURSELF I KNOW
THIS BECAUSE I HAVE THE HONDA
CLARITY RIGHT NOW AND IT'S
ABOUT FIVE TO SIX MINUTES MAX A
REVEALING TIME AND IS EXTREMELY
CONVENIENT FOR ME AND I'M NOT
EVEN A PARENT SO I CAN IMAGINE
BEING A PARENT OR HAVING TWO
JOBS HAVING TO GET FROM ONE
PLACE TO ANOTHER. I WOULD LOVE
TO HAVE GOOD OPTIONS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO BE ABLE TO
UTILIZE THE FUEL CELL ELECTRIC
VEHICLES I KNOW THIS IS
SPECIFICALLY A LIGHT DUTY
CONVERSATION THAT I'M HAVING
RIGHT NOW BUT I REALLY DO THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE
NEED TO HAVE OPTIONS FOR
CALIFORNIANS WHEN YOU KNOW 41%
OF OUR GHG EMISSIONS ARE DUE TO
TRANSPORTATION. SO I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THE BENEFITS OF THE
FUEL CELL ELECTRIC VEHICLES IS
THAT YOU CAN REVEAL SO QUICKLY
AND THAT IT COULD BE VERY
ACCESSIBLE BUT WE REALLY DO
NEED THAT INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
WAS TALKED ABOUT SO MUCH TODAY
IN ORDER TO ENABLE SO MANY OF
THE CALIFORNIANS TO REFUEL
THEIR ONLY THREE STATIONS. AND
SACRAMENTO RIGHT NOW AND SO I
DO TO PLAN OUT MY ROW. AND I
HAVE TO MAKE SURE I CAN. MAKE
IT TO AND FROM. I'D LIKE TO SEE
A LOT MORE OF MY NEIGHBORS
BEING ABLE TO HAVE THAT ACCESS-
AND MEET THAT GOAL SO WE COULD
HAVE ALL TYPES OF VEHICLES. TO
ASSIST US IN REACHING OUR GHG
EMISSIONS GOALS. SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR HAVING THIS.
COMMITTEE HEARING TODAY WE
REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO
ENGAGING. ALL THE OTHER TOPICS
THAT HYDROGEN CAN ASSIST WITH-
IN THE OTHER SECTORS TO
DECARBONISE CALIFORNIA SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. AND
NEXT UP. YES BILLERICAY THE
CALIFORNIA FUEL CELL
PARTNERSHIP AND I DON'T HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE PANEL OR
EVEN THE SPEAKERS BEFORE ME OR
THAT TOPICS YOU COVERED IT ALL
VERY WELL I WANT TO FOCUS ON
SOMETHING VERY PARTICULAR TO
CALIFORNIA AND A LEADER
POSITION WE BUILT. THE ZERO
EMISSION. MOSHE MOVEMENT I
REALLY STARTED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA OVER THIRTY YEARS
AGO IT DOES HAVE REGULATION IT
IS IT HAS BEEN INCREDIBLY
SUCCESSFUL NOT ONLY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BUT AROUND THE WORLD
SETTING THAT TONE AND THIS IS A
HUGE MOMENT FOR US ALL AS WE
REALLY SEE THE SUCCESS OF BOTH
BATTERIES AND FUEL CELLS GOING
FORWARD BOTH CLIMATE CHANGE AND
EVERYTHING ELSE HAPPENING WE
SEE THAT URGENCY WE'RE NOT
DOING ENOUGH WE NEED MORE OF
THIS ON THE GROUND. SOMETHING
THAT WAS BARELY TOUCHED UPON
EARLIER- DR MARTINEZ FROM CARB
TALKED ABOUT THE SELF
SUFFICIENCY STUDY. WE NEED TO
MOVE AWAY FROM SUBSIDIZING
THESE MARKETS FOR EVER AND
BUILDING THEM INTO SUSTAINABLE
SUPPLY AND DEMAND MARKETS. THAT
THE AVERAGE PERSON CAN GO OUT
AND TAKE THESE VEHICLES OFF THE
SHOW ROOM FLOOR AND LIVE THEIR
LIVES JUST WITH ZERO EMISSIONS.
THE LIGHT DUTY HYDROGEN FUEL
CELL VEHICLE REPORT TO SELF
SUFFICIENT SUFFICIENCY DRAFT
FROM CARP IS THE FIRST
IDENTIFIED PATHWAY. IN THE
WORLD. FOR A ZERO EMISSION
MARKET. CAN'T STATE THAT ENOUGH
I'LL GO ON A LIMB AND SAY MAYBE
YOU NEED AN ENTIRE HEARING SET
TO THAT TOPIC. BECAUSE THE
MOVEMENT THERE IN LIGHT DUTY
WILL ALSO BE LEVERAGED ENABLE
THE HEAVY DUTY MARKETS AND THEN
INTO SOME OF THE OTHER MARKET
OPPORTUNITIES FOR HYDROGEN THE
DOCTOR BROWER MENTIONED. AS
WELL AND AS WE LOOK AROUND THE
WORLD RIGHT NOW CALIFORNIA'S
BEEN THAT LEADER FOR DECADES.
HOWEVER IN THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS AROUND THE WORLD
EVERYONE'S PICKING UP ON
HYDROGEN TURN OVER THIRTY
COUNTRIES WHO HAVE INTEGRATED
HYDROGEN. INTO THEIR ENERGY
PLANTS NOT JUST FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT BUT FOR THE
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES. WE WERE
THE BIGGEST WE WERE THE LEADER
WE'RE LOSING GROUND WE NEED
THAT NOT FOR THE BOASTING
NATURE. BUT FOR THOSE
ENVIRONMENTAL URGENT BENEFITS
WE NEED NOW. AND THE ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES THAT COME WITH
IT. SO CONSIDER HOW THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO MAKE ALL OF THESE
ZERO EMISSION MARKETS GET TO A
STATE. WHERE IT'S SURE SUPPLY
AND DEMAND WE'RE BUILDING ON A
MARKET POTENTIAL AND THAT'S
WHAT THE SAID REGULATION WAS
THIRTY YEARS AGO THE INTENTION
WAS. SHOW US HOW TO BUILD THE
MARKET GET THERE SO WE CAN GET
OUT OF THIS SUBSIDY OPPORTUNITY
AND OUT OF THAT AND INTO A REAL
MARKET SO. JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THE INCREDIBLE REPORT
LOOKING FOR THAT DRAFT BEING
FINALIZED REALLY SOON IT'S BEEN
MANY MONTHS. AND THEN TALKING
ABOUT THAT AS THE WAY WE
TRANSITION CALIFORNIA. AND THE
REST OF THE WORLD THE ZERO
EMISSIONS. THANK YOU VERY GOOD
THANK YOU. AND YOU FOR YOUR
TEST- WE APPRECIATE HAVING YOU
HERE TODAY IN SACRAMENTO- THAT
SEAT NOW I THINK WOULD LIKE TO
GO AHEAD. AND GET ON TO THE
TELEPHONE LINES SO WOULD LIKE
TO THANK EVERYONE HERE WHO'S
FOR PICK THAT PARTICIPATED
SHOULD NOW VIA THE TELEPHONE
CONFERENCE SERVICE MODERATOR.
LET'S GO AHEAD AND OPEN UP THE
LINES AND PROP INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO PROVIDE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT AND WE WILL BEGIN
MODERATOR. WITH YOU'LL GET A
HOLD OF ONE PLACE. LA GERMAN IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENTS PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. YOUR
TONE INDICATING PLACING QUEUE
NUMBER WILL PROVIDE YOU A
NUMBER AND I WILL ANNOUNCE YOU
BY THAT NUMBER ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU'D LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AND THEN JUST YOU ARE AWARE WE
DO HAVE ABOUT SIX IN THE QUEUE.
ALL RIGHT. GO AHEAD MODERATOR
LET THE FIRST ONE ON. WE WILL
START WITH- NUMBER SEVENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES GO AHEAD WE
CAN HEAR YOU SPEAK UP- SO WE
CAN ALL HEAR YOU. SURE SENATOR
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. MY NAME'S MARK
MOBLEY. AND I AM- RETIRED
TAXPAYER. AND I'VE BEEN DRIVING
A HYDROGEN FUEL CELL CAR FOR
FIVE YEARS. AND I LOVE IT I
PURCHASED MINE. FIVE YEARS AGO.
AND I HAVE- GOT A LOAN FROM A
CREDIT UNION- SO IT'S BEEN FIVE
YEARS AND FORTY FOUR THOUSAND
MILES OF. ZERO EMISSION DRIVING
AND I'M ONE OF THE APARTMENT
DWELLERS- SO. IN MY CASE I
COULDN'T PLUG IN WITH A BATTERY
ELECTRIC. BUT HYDROGEN'S WORKED
PERFECTLY FOR ME. I JUST WANT
TO SAY. IF YOU'RE THINKING
ABOUT IT. THE PRICES ARE
DEFINITELY COME DOWN. ARE YOU
CAN GET A CERTIFIED PREOWNED-
FOR ABOUT A QUARTER OF WHAT I
PAID FIVE YEARS AGO. OKAY THANK
YOU MY WRITER NEXT ONE. THANK
YOU MY WRITER NEXT CALLER
NUMBERS SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR ARCHULETA FOR HER YOUR
PROFOUND LEADERSHIP AND THE
HYDROGEN POLICY BASED ON THE
BALLOT QUESTION OF COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS ROXANNE ABOUT MOMMY AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
WATSON ARJUN ALLIANCE JUST LIKE
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE. MENTIONED
BEFORE THERE'S OBVIOUSLY A
GREAT NEED FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
NOT BEING HYGIENE STATIONS
EXPLICITLY WOULD ALSO PRO
PRODUCTION AND DISTRIBUTION
YOUR FOR THE WORK THAT YOU'RE
DOING ON AS HE DISTRICTS HERE
AND ACTUALLY FIX WITH ME WHICH
WE'RE WORKING WITH YOU ON YOU
ACTUALLY OUR COMBINATION OF
THOSE- TO ACTUALLY ADDRESS SOME
OF THOSE THIS YEAR. THE OTHER
THING THAT I WANT TO SAY AS AN
ENTITY THAT IS WORKING IN THE
WESTERN STATE I WILL TELL YOU
CALIFORNIA. I'M THAT IS RIGHT I.
THOUGHT WE CAN MENTION. WERE IT
NOT LEADERS IN YOUR SPACE. WE
ARE MOVING AROUND AND I CAN
TELL YOU THAT. I Y. MORE WITH
PRODUCERS IN THE WEST STATE
THAT WANTED. YOU'LL BE
INTRODUCED WHAT YOU THINK SHE
CAN. WHY ARE WE NOT PRODUCE. A
WIRE WE NOT. I CAN ACT IN THE
STATE FOR ACTIVITIES THAT ARE
GOING IN THIS THAT WE USING TAX
DOLLARS. TO ACTUALLY BY THE
VEHICLES SHOULD BE GOOD AND
THINK WE SHOULD BE PROMOTE THE.
ALTHOUGH I WANT TO PAY THAT
THERE ARE OTHER. LIKE THAT THEY
DON'T. ORG HONDA. I'M NOT A
CRIMINAL LAW. BUT CERTAIN-
THINGS I MENTIONED THAT ARE
PROMOTE HIGHER POLICY. THAT
WILL POINT I BEHIND. SO I WANT
TO ENCOURAGE YOU. STOP LOOKING.
YOU HAVE TO CLEAN LOOK AT THE-
WORLD LOOK AT THE THAT. SHOULD
YOU KNOW BEHIND. ONE GATHERED
RETOOL. YEAH ARE YOUR
LEGISLATION. DOING WALGREENS.
CALIFORNIA YOU FOR YOUR CALL
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT TO GO
TO NUMBERS FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CAN YOU HEAR ME OK. YES YEAH-
THANK YOU FOR HOSTING US TODAY
IS FANTASTIC ANALYSTS WERE
FANTASTIC SORRY COULDN'T BE
THERE IN PERSON MY NAME IS JACK
TICKLE I'M ONE OF THE CO
FOUNDERS OF GREEN GREAT ANCHOR
LOCAL SAN RAMON COMPANY FOR
ABOUT A TEN YEAR OLD COMPANY
THAT HAVE BEEN WORKING ON KEY
TECHNOLOGIES AND SOLUTIONS FOR
CLIMATE ADAPTATION AND
RESILIENCY PROJECTS AND ONE OF
THOSE REALLY IMPORTANT AREAS
THAT WE'VE BEEN FOCUSED ON. FOR
A LONG TIME IS GREEN I. AND SO
I WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO FORM
A GROUP THAT. REHIRED AND HAS
MADE A LOT OF. ADVANCEMENTS IN
THE MOST RECENT FIVE YEARS. AND
TO PLEASE THINK ABOUT RETIRED
GENERAL STORE IN WIND ENERGY
AMONG OTHERS LIKE GEOTHERMAL
AND OTHER CLEAN ENERGY IS BUT
PRIMARILY CAN BE SOLAR AND WIND
ENERGY WHICH IS STORED FOR USE
AT A DIFFERENT TIME AND PLACE.
AND THIS IS SO FUNDAMENTAL
BECAUSE THIS CAN MODEL ALL OF
THE EXISTING BENEFIT OF OUR
GASOLINE AND CARBON BASED
SUPPLY CHAIN WHILE PROVIDING
CARBON FREE ENERGY SO. THIS
PROVIDE THE TYPE OF CLIMATE
ADAPTATION AND RESILIENCY THAT
WE REALLY NEED FOR MOBILITY AND
OUR ELECTRIC GRID. BECAUSE NOW
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
EVER PRESENT RISK OF PS PS
WHERE THE LECTURE UTILITIES MAY
TURN OFF THE ELECTRICAL POWER
LINES FOR OUR SAFETY. DUE TO
THE THREAT OF WILDFIRE. IN
HYDROGEN PROVIDE US WAY I'LL
HAVE ENERGY LETTER NOT
DEPENDENT ON OUR ELECTRIC
TRANSMISSION TRANSMISSION
SYSTEM SO IN CONTRAST A BATTERY
THANKS RADIO CALL- WORLD WITH
REQUIRE A VERY STRONG EMPHASIS
ON THE- LECTER TRANSMISSION
SYSTEM. AND WERE REALLY JUST
NOT THERE YET. WILL NOT BEING
ABLE TO- HAVE THAT FLEXIBILITY
WHETHER A GREEN HYDROGEN
ECONOMY IS VERY IMPORTANT TO US
IN TERMS OF OUR OUR CLIMATE
ADAPTATION AND RESILIENCY
REMEMBER A LOT OF TIMES SPOKE
LIKE TO CHARGE BATTERIES AT
NIGHT. AND NOT FOR THE
CONVENIENCE BECAUSE LONG CHARGE
TIME- BY THE WAY THE SUN IS
DOWN. SO THAT'S A WHOLE NOTHER
ISSUE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A
BATTERY CENTRIC SOLUTION TRULY
BECOME. A CLEAN ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE SYSTEM SO. THE
OTHER THING I'D LIKE TO. KNOW
IS THAT WE HAD EXCELLENT
STRIDE. A QUICK MATH FOR
HYDROGEN IN THE ROLLOUT OF THE
HYDROGEN GAS STATIONS. AS WELL
AS THE VEHICLES WHICH ARE
COMPLETELY HI NOMINAL. SO OUR
EMPHASIS THIS EVEN DATES BACK
TO THE DELETE PROGRAMS GOING
BACK INTO THE EIGHTIES AND
NINETIES AND EARLY TWO
THOUSAND. THE EMPHASIS WAS
ALWAYS ON THE DEMAND SIDE AND
WE HAVE NOT YET SEEN THE
EMPHASIS FOR- IN. STRONG
SUPPORT PROGRAM FOR REGULATIONS
AND INCENTIVES FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE SUPPLY SIDE
SO THAT'S WHERE GREEN GREEN
CONSTRUCTING. IT ON SOLVING THE
RENEWABLE HYDROGEN SUPPLY SIDE
ISSUES WE HAVE PATENTED
SOLUTIONS. THAT WILL REALLY.
REDUCE THE COST FOR DELIVERED
RENEWABLE HYDROGEN ATSCALE AND
WE'RE VERY HAPPY TO TELL YOU
THAT WE HAVE A RENEWABLE
HYDROGEN CAPACITY. RESERVATION
PROGRAM- GAS STATION OWNER WE
OWNERS AND ANYBODY LOOKING TO.
THEIR TRANSFER OR THE LIGHT
GRID. THE NEXT YEARS CAN
CONTACT BY UP THE START PLAN
FOR WINTER WHERE THEY'LL NEED A
CERTAIN DEGREE OF HYDROGEN FUEL
DELIVERED VERY GOOD. FOR YOUR
OVERALL GATHERED REDUCE THE
BEST PLAN. TO HELP ACHIEVE THE
ZERO EMISSION FUTURE THAT WE
ALL VERY GOOD. FOR YOUR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND LAZY GERMAN
YOU'VE GOT TO MANAGE. EACH SHOW
NEXT CALLER. NEXT IS NUMBER
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE GET HERE YES
OKAY THANK YOU- THANK YOU FOR
GIVING ME THIS OPPORTUNITY
TODAY- MY NAME IS NICHOLA
SHE'LL GET- WALKING I'VE GOT ON
THE STOCK MARKET BUT THE MOTOR
CITY BY ONE NATIONAL WHAT I
BELIEVE- I'VE BEEN DRIVING NOW.
SAID A COUPLE OF THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN OUR COST IT
OFF ON THE GROUND BEYOND THE
NOW BECAUSE OF THE TWENTY ONE
ARGUE THAT THE I R. YEAH I GET
TO GET A QUESTION ABOUT THE
BEAUTIFUL CAR QUITE OFTEN ON
THE IDEA WOULD PUBLIC- DO YOU
GO TO. PUT ANY PRETTY GOOD
BECAUSE IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN CUT
DOWN WALK THE GUY- CATHOLIC
KOCH SINCE THE DRIVING RANGES
ABOUT THE ON THE STREET THE
TIME IS THE SAME ACCORDING TO
THE CENTER HOBBY THERE ARE. YOU
OUT YEAH IT ALSO BE OB. TO FOR
ANYBODY YOU KNOW THAT THEIR NAY
UP- OUR ENERGY TO RUN ON. ON
THAT ARE AGREE WITH IT EVEN IF
THAT WAS AT THE LOOK. PEAK AND
I WILL TO DO. WE DON'T ON THE
INPUT THAT ONE TO REACH THAT
ARE YOU KNOW THAT MAKE A DEEPER.
PRACTICE SCHOOL. ABLE TO BUY
THE HOUSE GET ON BOARD THAT YOU.
ONE COOLEY NOT PROVIDE.
DIFFICULT ENVIRONMENTAL ON THE
THING THAT I THOUGHT. HE DID
BEFORE YOU COULD BE. ABU THE
CABLE. WELL LET'S GO BECAUSE ON
THE OP. ON- THE RANGE ON THE
ARE. THANK YOU- CENDRARS LAWN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS CHRIS PEOPLE I AM AN
ELECTED MEMBER OF THE ALAMEDA
CONTRA COSTA TRANSIT DISTRICT
BOARD AND I WANT TO AMPLIFY A
LITTLE BETTER ON. WHAT MY VICE
MAYOR AND MY FORMER COLLEAGUE
ON HE BOARD. REBECCA KAPLAN
HAD THIS SAY ABOUT OUR HYDROGEN
FUEL CELL PROGRAM- AS YOU
MENTIONED WE HAVE BEEN
OPERATING HYDROGEN FUEL CELL
BUSES. FOR ABOUT TWENTY YEARS
NOW WE RECENTLY ADDED TO THAT
LEAD A SMALL CLEAN WHICH IS
GETTING BIGGER OF BATTERY
ELECTRIC BOXES. AND WE ARE
OPERATING THE FIRST IN THE
WORLD FORMAL COMPARISON
BETWEEN. FUEL CELL ELECTRIC
BOXES BATTERY ELECTRIC BUSES
DIESEL ELECTRIC BUSES AND
DIESEL BOXES- IT'S BEEN NOT
BEING OPERATED BY AC TRANSIT.
AND ANALYZED AND MONITORED BY
EN ROUTE THE NATIONAL RENEWABLE
ENERGY LAB. AND TEAM OUT OF
STANFORD UNIVERSITY. SO THE
FIRST WHO ARE BORN ON THAT WAS
PUBLISHED- A FEW WEEKS AGO THE
NEXT ONE IS DUE IN DECEMBER AND
THE FORMAL ACADEMIC PAPER THE
BILL IN ABOUT TWO YEARS. SO
THAT WILL PROVIDE MUCH
INFORMATION BOTH WERE GRANTED
AGENCIES WHO ARE INTERESTED. IN
WHAT SORT OF A LIKE GREG. ALL
CONTINUES AND FOR ALL OTHER
HEAVY DUTY USERS. NAME SECOND
THING I'D LIKE TO COMMENT ON IS
THE DRAMATIC DROP IN PRICE OVER
THOSE TWENTY YEARS- THE-
LAWSUIT WE ARE BUYING TODAY
COSTS LESS THAN HALF WHAT THOSE
ORIGINAL BOXES. DID AND AS THEY
COME IS THE QUANTITY GROW WE
EXPECT THE PRICE WILL DROP DOWN
AS WELL. ENGENDER WE REGULARLY
USE TOWARDS OF OUR FACILITIES I
DID ONE YESTERDAY AND WE DID
ONE TODAY AND SO WE WOULD LOG.
TO APPROACH YOU ON A TOUR OF
OUR YOU ONLY AND. PRODUCTION I
DO CHEN COULD NOT IT'S ALL
THESE ANYTIME YOU WANT COME
DOWN THANK YOU VERY MUCH VERY
GOOD THANK YOU FOR THE IMPACT.
AND SEND A COPY OF YOUR REPORT
FINDING A IT'S GOOD. NEXT CALL
PLEASE. NEXT IS NUMBER SEVENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SERRA GRIS
AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
JUSTICE AND I'D LIKE TO THANK
FOUNDER ARCHULETA FOR BRINGING
THE DEATH PENALTY GATHER ON
VERY INFORMATIVE. MY COMMENT
TODAY IS- EARNS- ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE-
COULDN'T AWARE OF ONE- VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT COULD-
UNDERMINE- NOBLE HAIGER DAN'S
ABILITY TO DELIVER AND BAYERN
MENTAL BENEFITS TO CALIFORNIA
AND THAT IS CURRENTLY.
COMPANIES THAT PRODUCE HYDROGEN
ARE CLAIMING THAT THAT HYDROGEN
IS RENEWABLE EVEN WHEN IT'S
PRODUCED USING NATURAL GAS
THROUGH A PROCESS CALLED STEAM
REFORMATION- AND- THEY'RE ABLE
TO DO THAT THROUGH THE LEGAL
FICTION OF HERRING NATURAL GAS.
BOB WHAT CONTRACTS FOR- THINGS
LIKE GAS FROM A CATTLEMAN FROM
OUT OF STATE FARMS- AND THE
PROCESS OF CREATING THIS
HYDROGEN FROM NATURAL GAS- IS
OFTEN LOCATED WHERE- WILL
REFINERIES AND A METS VERY
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF NANAK
AND OTHER HEALTH HARMING
POLLUTION IN THE SAME
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE ALREADY
OVERBURDENED WITH POLLUTION
FROM THE REFINERY SECTOR- THIS
IS AN OVERSIGHT IN OUR CURRENT
POLICY IS THAT THE- LEGISLATURE
HAS AN OPPORTUNITY THANKS. AND
I HOPE IT WILL EXPLORE DOING SO
IN THE FUTURE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CALL NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO OTHERS
IN OUR QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE. A
MODERATOR WOULD YOU CHECK ONE
MORE TIME SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
ELSE ON THE LINE. ABSOLUTELY
AND IF ANYONE ELSE ON THE LINE
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENTS PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR PUBLIC
COMMENTS- AT THIS TIME THERE
ARE NO OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE VERY
GOOD THANK YOU I'D LIKE TO
THANK EVERYONE WHO PARTICIPATED
IN THIS- FIRST SELECT COMMITTEE
ON HYDROGEN ENERGY CALIFORNIA
IS A TREASURE CHEST OF ENERGY
AND THE GOAL OF THIS SELECT
COMMITTEE IS TO ENSURE THAT
HYDROGEN HAS ITS PLACE IN THAT
TREASURE CHEST OF ENERGY WE
KNOW THAT HYDROGEN WILL PLAY A
ROLE IN THE HELPING AND HELPING
CALIFORNIA TRANSITION TO ZERO
CARBON. AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
USING THIS SELECT COMMITTEE AS
A CALTRANS FOR THE CONVERSATION
INFORMATION ON HYDROGEN WE HAVE
A LOT TO WORK TO DO NO DOUBT
BUT TOGETHER IN CALIFORNIA AND
AS CALIFORNIANS WE CAN
ACCOMPLISH ANYTHING THANK YOU
ALL FOR THE AND THE ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO CALLED IN TODAY
FOR THE PUBLIC COMMENTS AND
TESTIMONY AND- IF YOU ARE NOT
ABLE TO CALL IN. VIA THE
TELEPHONE ARE YOU PLEASE YOU
CAN SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING- TO THE
WEBSITE OR HERE IN THE STATE
CAPITAL- YOUR SUBCONSCIOUS
DIGESTION WILL BE PUT ON THE
RECORD TO INCLUDE ANY TESTIMONY
AND- ANY HEARING THAT YOU YOU
HAVE PERTAINING TO THE- THE
HEARING TODAY WE'D LIKE TO
THANK YOU AND APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION WE WOULD LIKE TO-
HANG ON JUST ONE SECOND. AND
I'D LIKE TO THANK EVERYONE WHO
AND THEIR PATIENT FOR
COOPERATION TODAY AND- BEFORE
WE CONCLUDE THE AGENDA I'D LIKE
TO GO AHEAD TURN IT OVER. TO
THE PANELISTS TO SEE IF THEY'D
LIKE TO HAVE SOME CLOSING
REMARKS. PANELIST YOU'RE
WELCOME TO JAPAN. GO AHEAD THE
NOW THAT- DOCTOR GO RIGHT AHEAD.
I WAS POINTING JERRY BACK OUT
TO HAVE HER GO FIRST. WELL JUST
WANTED TO TELL YOU WHAT WAS
GOING ON AND WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
DO THAT. WE'LL AND WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND DO THAT REBEKAH.
ADVICE SURE GO RIGHT AHEAD WITH
YOUR CLOTHES REMARKS IN. WILL
GO DOWN FOR MY SCREEN I WAS AT.
EXCELLENT THANK YOU SO MUCH
SENATOR I STILL APPRECIATE THIS
IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY I DID
WANT TO SHARE THAT I. HAVE
POSTED INTO THE ZOOM CHAT THE
LINKS. FOR THOSE WONDERFUL
REPORTS THAT MY COLLEAGUE CHRIS
PEOPLE'S FROM THE AC TRANSIT
BOARD MENTIONED ABOUT THE
COMPARISON OF THE DIFFERENT
BUSES. AND THE GREAT
RELIABILITY OF THE HYDROGEN
BUSES AND HOW MUCH THEIR PRICES
COME DOWN AND I THINK THAT
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT. THAT
WE CAN INVEST IN A WAY THAT
WILL TURN THE COST CURVE. GOING
FORWARD I ALSO WANT TO THANK
THE CENTER FOR TRANSPORTATION
AND THE ENVIRONMENT WHICH IS AN
ESSENTIAL ROLE IN THE BRINGING
OF THE HYDROGEN FUEL CELL
TRUCKS. TO THE PORT OF OAKLAND
AND I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT WE
ARE ALSO WORKING ON ONE OF THE
SPEAKERS MENTIONED THE
CLASSIFIED IN SIX TRUCKS. THE
DELIVERY TRUCKS THE TYPES ONE
MIGHT ASSOCIATE WITH FEDEX OR
UPS WE ARE WORKING TO HAVE
HYDROGEN FUEL IN FOR THOSE AS
WELL AND TO MAKE THAT AN
OPTION. AND WE HAVE BEGUN
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT HYDROGEN FUEL
CELL FOR RAIL- IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH VALLEY LINK- WHICH IS A
RAIL PROJECTS- WITH ALAMEDA
COUNTY AND OUR NEIGHBORING
COUNTIES. AND SO- I BELIEVE
THOSE ARE COMEDIANS WHO SAID
GIVE ME ONE FIXED POINT FROM
WHICH I CAN MOVE THE EARTH. AND
ONCE WE HAVE THE SUFFICIENT
FUELING STATIONS THAT CREATE
THE CONFIDENCE OF BEING ABLE TO
USE THIS TECHNOLOGY THEN MORE
AND MORE USERS CAN AND WILL
ADOPT IT. AND LASTLY WE WOULD
LOVE TO WORK TOGETHER TO BRING
SUSTAINABLE LOCALLY PRODUCED
HYDROGEN IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
OUR WASTE WATER UTILITY AND THE
PORT. WORKING TOGETHER AND SO
THAT YOU CAN BE PART OF OUR
FUTURE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HAVING ME. YOU'RE GOOD THANK
YOU LET ME GO OUT. OF THE WAY
WE- UP THE LADDER HERE SO LET'S
GO WITH THE MEASURE TO RUSSIA.
YOU CAN. GIVE US SOME CLOSING
REMARKS AND WILL GO THE OTHER
WAY. SO MICHELLE ROSS OF PLACE.
I JUST AGAIN WANT TO THANK THE
YOURSELF IN. THE COMMITTEE FOR
ALLOWING US TO TESTIFY IN. I
YOU'RE A IT WAS A- VERY
WORTHWHILE- CALL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. BOB THIS TIME
IN. PLEASE IF YOU CAN GIVE US
SOME CLOSING REMARKS IF YOU'RE
STILL WITH US. AGAIN YOU ARE.
GOING THE OTHER COMMENTS CENTER
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
ORGANIZING THE SOMETIMES- WERE
HAPPY TO PROVIDE OUR INPUT I
THINK- ALL THE PANELISTS ARE
COMING FROM A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE BUT WE HAVE THE
SAME OBJECTIVES AND- I LOOK
FORWARD TO. CONTINUING
DISCUSSION AND WORKING
TOGETHER. VERY GOOD AND LASTLY
MORE. EUROPE NEXT WITH CLOSING
REMARKS. AND I JUST WANNA THANK
YOU SENATOR AND THE COMMITTEE
FOR YOU KNOW ALLOWING ME TO
TESTIFY AND SHARE OUR
EXPERIENCE WITH OUR HYDROGEN
FLEET PROGRAM. AND YOU KNOW TO
MY FELLOW PANELISTS- ARE YOU
SENATOR IF YOU EVER WISH TO
HEAR ANYMORE FEEDBACK. FROM OUR
FLEET TEAM I'M HAPPY TO PROVIDE
AT. THANK YOU AND- LET'S SEE WE
GOT- ANDREW MARTINEZ UP NEXT
ANDREW PLEASE YOU'VE GOT THE
FLOOR. DOES NOT JUST THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
TODAY BUT- I DO NOT HAVE ANY
FURTHER ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. CAN CLOSE
IT UP- DOCTOR BROWER GO AHEAD
YOU'VE GOT THE FLOOR. THANK YOU
SO MUCH I DO APPRECIATE THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND- CONVENING
THIS I WANTED TO MAKE ONE LAST
COMMENT ON THAT IS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE FACT THAT WE HAVE
SPENT A LOT OF TIME TODAY
TALKING ABOUT TRANSPORTATION
APPLICATIONS BUT WE NEED TO
ENGENDER. ZERO EMISSIONS IN
EVERY APPLICATION AND HYDROGEN
OFFERS OPPORTUNITIES AND
FEATURES THAT YOU CAN'T GET
WITH ANYTHING ELSE THAT IS ZERO
EMISSIONS FOR STATIONARY POWER
FOR INDUSTRY AND WE'RE REALLY
DIFFICULT TO DECARBONISE
APPLICATIONS LIKE STEEL AND
CEMENT AND THINGS LIKE THIS-
AND THAT WE MUST ALSO
DECARBONISE SO WHEN I MAKE SURE
THAT OUR STATE ALSO LEADS IN
THESE AREAS AS WELL- SO THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU AND LIKE TO THANK
STAFF AND EVERYONE WHO
PARTICIPATED AND BUT IN THIS
MEETING TOGETHER AND I THANK
YOU I'D CERTAINLY LIKE TO
THANK. THE PRO TEM FOR ALLOWING
US- THIS ROOM IN THIS TIME AND
TO WITH THAT- I WOULD LIKE TO
LET EVERYONE THAT SAY THANK YOU
HAVE A PLEASANT WEEK. AND THIS
MEETING IS ADJOURNED.